greetings podcastville uncle joey here
the church of what's happening now
coming to you
and brought to you by
onyx.com listen for all your
supplemental needs honor is the way to
go trust what i'm telling you from
shroom tech to hemp force protein shake
it's going to make you
feel tremendous
go to honey.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off also let me
explain something to you throw out the
stigma that being well-dressed will cost
you a fortune all right because at the
5-4 club
they found a way to make great looking
clothes affordable for everybody
chris paul mark wahlberg used the 5-4
club and the 5-4 club has been featured
in gq vice and in style joey what's the
4-5 club you got 100
worth 120 worth to close for just 60 a
month all right let's do this before we
even get the party started go to
fivefourclub.com right now and at the
promo code joey and they're gonna give
you 50 off your first month package plus
a free pair of sunglasses you know what
i'm saying you know look like joe
mama luke from 148th street that's 50
off your first package at the 5-4 club
spelled
f-i-v-e-f-o-u-r club.com
promo code joey 54club.com
promo code joey hit it lee
[Music]
tuesday
are you kidding me or what
we're kicking this [__] mule early
here october 2nd throwing [__] heat
on you on a monday night my brother nick
tuturo's on here shows up with a pizza
and blue cheese
pizza dough rolls something gentiles
would [__]
these [__] kids would pay an extra
six bucks from pizza pizza to get those
things delivered they get that staminkia
[__] what they delivered to you fresh
mozzarella sticks with a pizza you can't
[__] for a [__] week get constipated
you might as well eat 20 [__] uh
vicodins he called them bombs and get
some awesome these are bombs
these will clog up your little muffler
what's happening beautiful people lisa
ayat here uncle nick nick is here before
we even start this
my heart goes out our heart goes out to
the victims in las vegas
it's a different [__] world out there
and uh thank god we have each other
because
this you know what a way to wake up on a
monday morning
i could say it's a beautiful day to be
10 [__] times today and nothing made
a difference
by 10 o'clock i went to write and i
couldn't even write thank god [__] uh
bert crisis showed up
and i talked to him until about 10 to 11
and then finally i go what am i gonna do
sit here
and think about you know going to a show
or going to a football game and getting
[__] shot now in this day and age
yeah
so i finally went to jiu jitsu and that
was great for an hour when i got home
and then tonight i watched world news
tonight
and at one point i just started crying i
mean these people were all 23 24
27.
35 with three kids at home
you know i mean to be standing outside
and to be [__] targeted like that i
mean there was nowhere to go
the guy he they were all like john f
kennedy's poor [__] people that's
what they were they were john f
kennedy's they were trapped in there and
this was a [__] another
so my heart goes out to you people and
uh the people listening
i know today was a hard day for you guys
too it's a crazy world ain't it i was
just talking a couple of weeks ago it's
a guy and we're arguing about you know i
said the world today is nothing like
when i grew up not that it was perfect
in the 70s and the 80s but you know you
didn't you didn't see this kind of [__]
that's become like the norm
the last 10 15 years and these mass
killings and children and just people
that are at a concert at a movie and you
get massacred you get blown away i mean
these world technology and we're curing
things and i don't give a [__] it's a
it's really a world that's become like a
video game and it's a shame because
you know people's lives can be like
snuffed out in a second i i just can't
understand the mindset
of of
the maniacs that do this they inflict
so much and then they blow themselves up
and 64 years oh he doesn't fit the
profile well obviously you didn't know
the [__] guy there's no profile
anymore what profile yeah
how do you know who the guy next to you
i mean today you're not safe anywhere
anywhere and um i know it's just sad i
mean i'm not a gun guy either that's why
i don't like guns period he had 18 guns
here had 19 guns over there
i don't know what the answer is anymore
the [__] did he get these guns and this
is why he passed he passed the the
whatever it is the checks
the checks oh no no no i'm not talking
about the guns what i'm trying to say to
you people is
what do i tell everybody all the time
fall in up with christ put that [__]
phone in your pocket
the love of christ when you're walking
you have to pay attention i want you to
walk around like this is the bronx
and any of these people can mug you i
don't give a [__] if you're in a church
because that's how you have to walk now
you have to watch
and look you have to live like you're
selling drugs now
that's how you have to live when you
walk into a room before you take a seat
you have to [__] uh sit next to an
exit and sit with your [__] door your
face at the [__] door and you have to
know where the other doors are when you
sit down and if there ain't no other
doors you know what get up and go to the
bathroom and see if there's a way to
[__] out of that because that's the only
way you can live now guys
nobody wants to get slaughtered these
people got slaughtered last night
that's what they did
they got slaughtered 500 and something
people got injured yeah that means shot
shot
period injured a bullet he shot bullets
that would go through
body piercing on cops
oh no this was a horrible [__] night
for this country there was a horrible
night for the world
and somebody was in entertainment what
do you want me to think anymore what do
you want me to think anymore
these comedy clubs except the punch
lines have [__] metal detectors yeah
you know i was going to say 10 years ago
i i lived in israel for six months
and they they have metal detectors at
malls
they have metal detectors everywhere and
it's just something that you deal with
alex jones
six at the ufc in houston
six seven years ago with all his
craziness and all his thing he's pretty
crazy we were sitting there talking and
he goes i predict
and he said in five years so he's off a
year that we were going to start having
tsa at parks
tsa concerts
tsa at malls tsa everywhere you walked
into
csa was going to take over the united
states you walk into a [__] bodega
and they'll be a tsa agent dead in 20
years as weird as it sounds and i i
could be misremembering some of it but
it felt like there was a lot of soldiers
doing the like the uh checking in israel
and
i felt safer there than
sometimes than i do here at tsa like
they felt morbid feels more professional
they didn't it wasn't messing around it
was a quick check and you were through
and
yeah like i felt totally so i was an 18
year old kid who didn't speak the
language and i never once felt
uh like in danger or anything and i'm
gonna tell you people something
i'm gonna tell you something from the
deepest valley of my heart because you
guys know i fly
and you guys know i've been flying for
20 years when it comes to flying i'm a
[__] professional i'll tell you what
they
you know xfo i'll tell you [__] xna
you know what's xna airport you've been
landing xna northern arkansas [__]
airport listen i can drop knowledge on
you that most people don't know you know
i know all about flying points lee how
much do i get upgraded
97 of the time i know every scam every
[__] but he also wakes up at like
three a.m to call sometimes
sure you got to do what you got to do
you got to sacrifice you got to take
over the [__] team
you want to hang out with [__]
doctors you got to [__] uh yeah play
the assistant got to dress up in white
and i'm going to tell you guys something
i could not me i didn't say me i'm sorry
that came out of my mouth
anybody could sneak a bomb on a plane
i'm telling you guys as a [__]
observer
i go through there every [__] twice a
weekend i go through tsa
four times a month
and i'm and after 20 after uh since 9 11
i got to tell you something that
i don't feel safe at all
that's sad
that's the because you could you could
bring something on there with lee
okay i could bring one piece lee could
bring the other piece and you could
bring the third piece
and together
they become something
right
okay
we all meet in the first bathroom you
make the right
i go in the big handicap store because
i'm the fat guy i put it together
and i could go on a plane i could go on
a [__]
i could go on a line i can do anything
i've seen it i've seen i sit there and
go wow
i get through with a vaping pen i get
through with
you know stupid stuff that should shine
through that you should stop me and go
take that out of the bag let's see what
that is
my ipad i don't take my ipad out don't
they tell you that when you get that
take your thing out you don't take your
ipad out never goddamn it joey that's
why well they never they never talk to
you about it never god most of the times
i let the ipad go the ipad goes in my
sleep apnea bag
before that because i had a bigger sleep
apnea bag and i put my computer in there
and i'm going to play with the surface
you can go on there with it but yeah you
never take it out you know they tell you
to take it out of the bag i never took
it out [__] you
if i take anything out i take the sleep
apnea machine bag out
but i'm telling you there's an amateur
that i've been watching there that i sit
there and watch them like when i'm going
through the line dog my heart's pounding
i feel like i'm about to steal something
and i'm not doing anything you know why
because i have no trust yeah because i
know at any minute i can hear abdullah
bach and [__] ba boom my life's over
next you know i'm on eyewitness news
they got my sneakers on there and one
sock the other one clung onto my fun guy
toe
yeah so that's the truth i'm telling you
in my opinion
but it's 98 accurate yeah and i'm not a
[__] terrorist or nothing like that
i'm telling you how they could do it i'm
not like i don't want the military to
take over like the country or anything
but don't you think if we hire had like
soldiers that were manning the airports
don't you think we feel safer
like manning
let me tell you something
i don't know uh what dimension you live
in going to lax some days dog
you think they're there to get pablo oh
they have people there i'm not saying i
feel no no no no
there's some more i've told you i fly
early and i get on there with an edible
and i don't go through changes when i
flatter on 10 o'clock right that's the
fear of death
that means you're getting there at 8 30.
you're checking in
you checked in already and you go
outside for that last breath of [__]
fresh air
look around you
look around you it's guys with [__]
big ones yeah
and go to kennedy airport
kennedy airport they're prepared for
[__] a war
go to kennedy airport they're prepared
for a [__] war oh they're very
prepared they have to be kennedy they're
prepared for a [__] war in new york
if you go through uh let me tell you
something if you buy a cheap ticket and
go through kennedy one of the italians
say model nami
that's what i got to tell you because
they have a thing at kennedy airport
well you know how they tell you two
hours before flight let's pretend you go
on check and it takes you 22 minutes and
you check in
the [__] security won't let you on
until a certain time period
so you got to wait in line like mook
deville
that's why you're going to get there
exactly like what i told you happened
happened pre-tsa has been over absorbed
the last two weekends i've flown out i
just got in the express first-class
light and then there were two people
pre-tsa i fly with sweats now so i don't
lose there's no belt to take off right
they tell ya so if you're pre-tsa and
you hold your license up with the ticket
you're good they don't make you take
your shoes off right and then there's
two people everybody now is pre-tsa
everybody yeah that's it they just sold
the [__] dream now to a bunch of
moose i didn't pay for it and eventually
you fly so much they give it to you
anyway yeah you can buy it that's what i
didn't buy it you can buy it right
and i'm a felon like a [__] soon
as i call the airlines your [__]
record comes up on the airline did you
know that oh really sure soon as you
call the airline as soon as your number
goes into their bank now since 9 11
everything of yours pops up they just
test you and [__] with you
who's this calling they [__] know
who's calling your name comes up your
address what you do if you've flown with
them before your visa card number your
amex number they got it all how do i
know because i know these things
[Laughter]
you're a beautiful baby i have friends
of friends what's going on in your life
[__] all right how you doing i'm
getting ready for the playoffs tomorrow
night this is your [__] world it's my
time yeah you know my hardcore yeah make
you feel like i throw away everything i
thought about it over the weekend you
know i love you i know you want to act i
know you want to be vito corleone but
listen
there's no there's no there's no value
in that no there isn't let me tell you
what the show is called see it's too
late now
now you got to start it up till next
year
this show is you in a room by yourself
yeah with a pizza
that's it okay with the yankee game
along with no sound
and you watching the yankee game that's
no problem listen to me it's 10 bucks to
watch the game with uncle nicki
it's good listen to me that's it no tv
show so tell me again ten ten ten
dollars ten dollars i could buy a season
pass
if they pay you they give you a for the
first month they give you ten dollars a
day
no five dollars a day for the first
month
or sixty dollars for a month if you do
the first day you get a two-day trial
with nikki t
but i'm going to tell you something
they don't mean nothing with nikki t
till the season starts getting closed
and nikki t starts going [__] bananas
right and for the extra fin they see the
tweets on the screen right and that's it
everything that you throw to anger yeah
and then somebody has to come in as soon
as they lose this is the reality of it
because reality television is scripted
yeah it is okay and then when it when
the yankees are losing right they do
like two hours
somebody has to open the door and ask
you like a stupid question can i ask you
a question
what's the capital of tennessee
and you're like [__] you
[__] you [__] your mother get the [__]
out of here
oh [__] never see a little rascals that
episode it was the little rascals
with chubby
and chubby was jealous because the
teacher was coming over
so alfalfa went over there and tried to
mark on the teacher
and our fafsa is all dressed up mm-hmm
he bring no no no no no no no it's the
chubby kid oh he calmed his hair chubby
absolutely chosen
she calls him something she calls him
like lunatic like a leonard yeah and he
goes you don't have to call me lettuce
you can call me just be husband chefs
yeah she's like 40. he's like [__]
12. and he's trying to mac out on this
episode let me let's see if it's on
what what was the other what was that
google chubsy obviously now google
youtube
chubs oh i love job jobs
funny [__] gun
when [__] alfalfa comes out and
starts making noise from the curtain
that is one of the funniest things
because every time chubbs be usb
runs his game right before she could say
something alfalfa comes out from behind
the curtain and torches them that's what
you need
that's part of this reality show
is that you sit there watch the yankees
and if they're losing
people have to come and torment your
life stupid questions what happens if
they're winning if they're winning
they're nobody it's okay nobody bothers
and people drop off but it's not funny
but the thing is for me
like tomorrow night will be you know
that's the real [__] so let's see just
be honest oh y'all look at that face
holy [__] look at that joey the third
one down the first one the first one
first one
look at this episode this brilliant
chubsby oh look at this
jackie cooper jackie cooper
[Music]
here he is
pleased
wow what do you want
oh this is brilliant i
thought i'd drop in
just keep passing by till you come to
the river and then drop in
wow
oh aren't they pretty
i brought you some candy
hey how did you get in here
oh i just flew in
this is private
[Music]
i have something heavy on my heart all
right this is classic
this is brilliant it says on a piece of
candy how about a kiss
some call me norman
call me chubsy
[Music]
what's the [__] putty this is the
[__] i grew up on i know me too
watch this
[Applause]
ladies
there's gonna be something heavy on your
nose
oh my god every time he tries to run
game watch
there's something heavy on
[Laughter]
oh me at that
[__]
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god jesus joey
i was a little kid who likes to watch
this [__] time left
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh this is great
oh [__]
[Music]
oh my god oh
[__] brilliant
no no it's brilliant it takes me back to
being a little kid this is what i was oh
there's space hold on hold on hit on the
blackwood kid oh my god this is when
they make the [__] cake there's that
[__] look at that up there
right there that one
click on that one that's when they make
the [__] cake
this is something that 1932 guys
i saw this every time i saw this episode
was gonna come on
speed it up speed it up when they make
the cake and the cake blows up i'll tell
you
he needs money to buy his mom a dress
so right there
all right
so they make a cake
and they just push it in the [__]
cake
it's time to put in them
so they get all this stuff this is as
racist
as could [__] be
this episode
is this racist baby
[Music]
they're putting toys in the cake
so they they're making a cake to sell it
by the slice
and then get the donations and buy their
mom a dress
because the husband wouldn't let her get
this is these are great stories
speed it up a little bit
so they start putting shoes in the
[__] batter all right they're putting
all this [__] in here yeah they put
their right there
i remember this this there's a scene
here
where it gets hot in the [__] kitchen
and he goes like this to sweat and he
throws the sweat on the wall and there's
black sweat
no there's not yes there is look at the
oven watch this blow up watch this watch
this this is
this [__]
this noise um i heard this every day at
school at least once a week and the
music is great you hit the music yeah
this is
oh
oh my god
it's [__] brilliant
even as a child i would give him
oh yeah that noise
did you
torture your teachers with this noise
every [__]
oh day god i haven't laughed
i haven't seen this yes i forgot how
funny this is how comedy started my
heart guys this is before the honeymoon
is for me
are these like your first joints
surprise
what's this [__]
flower shot out
and hit poor [__] buckwheat in the
face
look at him he takes a [__] shoe
oh he's got a hot water bottle this has
a surprise
[Music]
what was her justification for putting
these things in the cake a pride look at
this
[Laughter]
they couldn't make comedy like this
today no if they [__] this was kids
[__] geniuses
this is
this is so they don't like they don't
got kids like this anymore they can't do
this kind of stuff no more i just want
you to put it you dare enter this house
okay and see little rascals but little
rascals
you dare enter this house
this is great just watching this
this makes me [__] brings me back to
my my childhood i'm watching this i want
to be on the couch
every once in a while i'm in a hotel
room it's one in the morning i got
insomnia and you put this on i put this
[__] on and i [__] giggle
my [__] ass off oh my god
all right you dead for this house little
guys
let's see if it comes up scroll and
let's see nah that nobody even there you
go i talk about it oh you're talking
about ask you joey yeah you talk about
you then for this house
that's a great episode they go into this
[__] haunted house
the other one that's good is when they
[__] make the car and it's got a a a
boxing glove yeah and whatever people
are standing at the light oh the glove
the box yeah
punches into the face yeah yeah yeah i
remember that one and they steal the
cart and they're going down the hill and
guys when you're a kid man and you're
having a bad day maybe you [__] up a
word no this was great between this and
the three stooges yeah and then the
honeymoon and the honeymooners came in
later on and that was it [__]
brilliant you just last night i went
home what was the episode that was on
last night jesus christ
the golfer oh he had to play golf last
week was the [__] when he was the
superintendent of the bill it's on
sundays at eleven at eleven eleven
o'clock every [__] sunday yeah the
[__] golf always great they're all
great they're all right and the comedy
and you watch that type of comedy in
that style and the the catalyst was
quite carney well he was there but
gleason is a [__] really a great
actor he was a piano he was a dramatic
actor
so that's why in in off offset with uh
arkhani it was just
genius ah connie i watched some of those
episodes and again i [__] die oh it's
great
it's just the [__] lines you remember
hey ralph you want to take another bump
you know when you're in the [__]
train going the wrong way that was one
of the most brilliant episodes oh it's
[__] great how about one more ball
yeah how about another bump get up yeah
get up get up there get up there get up
there play shows wrapped yeah the mask
and everything oh my god yes it's comedy
that
i don't you know listen who knows how
you get to knack to do comedy
no i will tell you one thing uh nick
and you know there's there's things in
your life that you remember forever
and i still remember going to dune
buggy's house and him being on heroin
and us listening to the beatles me and
his little brother listen to the beatles
and them coming in on heroin like
the [__] you [__] listening to i
knocked the [__] out of both these
you know i'm a scared kid he's telling
him he's gonna knock the [__] out of us
let me show you what the [__] to listen
to
and he put on richard pryor
and that was it for me between richard
pryor and and jackie gleason
i was off to a different level i i was
confused
i didn't know what comedy was well here
it is [__]
this is as good as it gets you know
right then i got introduced to george
carl and david brother
but at first that was it and then red
fox came into the game yeah and i
literally had a heart attack on [__]
tv but then i bought his albums i bought
two of his albums i gotta tell you some
at the age of 12 the red fox album is a
little too strong did you go see anybody
live when you were at that ain't no
between you and i
i saw one comic before i got on stage
how old were you when you did your first
you know
comedy thing
[Music]
so how old were you 28 years old you
were 28
first time i got on stage how were you
the first time you acted um
like
you know professionally yeah in my late
20s like around that age yeah what was
the first
how when when did you get into acting
class when did you
yeah it was uh
probably because i you know i let it go
for a long time and did a little bit in
high school senior i was uh in musical
guys and dolls and then i didn't you
know finish college i dropped out and
so i had never really done anything
professionally you know until like i was
in my late 20s and more better blues
with spike lee uh that was the first
like real job you know all these great
guys were in the movie and robin harris
and
denzel washington i was like wow i can't
believe i'm i don't even know how this
[__] happened but
you know i had done something for spike
and then he
lied to me and just gave me a shot but i
had been taking acting class with this
guy bob motaka at night i was toying
with the idea and then
i said wow this is actually this is a
[__] i hope i just don't suck you
know i just even though i was acting
with my brother he was up and coming and
all these people in the movie were good
so i was like you know i was just i just
wanted to blend in you know but i
remembered after the the two weeks i
took off from the hotel as a door
doorman
after it was over my brother said you
know don't don't forget what happened
here don't forget the experience
because you could tell something kind of
changed in me and and i didn't forget i
was affected by the whole thing
but i was like wow this is way [__]
harder than i thought i saw denzel i was
like this guy is great i saw robin
harris i said who's that guy
he destroyed a whole room of people he
was like kind of a modern day red fox
he was really he was [__] brilliant
he was funny and he could act too he had
like some soul the first time it's a
real song do the right thing i lost my
oh my god he was on the street dick
willie yeah and he was next to a guy
that throws heat too yeah that played
the jamaican right that guy was a good
veteran savage yeah we went to see that
in new york with spike i mean
all black audience it was like out of
body experience everybody was screaming
laughing you know
that's it man you go that was a wild
audience that well that was a that was a
wild movie it's crazy that there were
two movies and i talked about this all
the time there's two movies that
i was not going to see harlem nights and
do the right thing
well one signed up for a sociology class
intro to sociology class
one of those [__] classes something
like that the teacher that was the
homework assignment yeah to watch do the
right thing and do a paper on the whole
[__] day and i gotta taste like it
blew my [__] mind
it's a good movie it blew my [__]
it's a [__] good movie till today it
still blows my mind yeah well that movie
just you know just [__] worked it
just kind of
it hit a nerve i don't know for the time
everything for me
it's funny it reminded me of being home
yeah it reminded me of the racial listen
anyone in new york understands oh my
glacial tension it's different there
than out here no no no no way different
that was a different racial tension let
me tell you what type of racial tension
that was
and do you remember this it was subtle
but it was light it was funny that yeah
you're still dating that spectre you're
right oh do you understand yeah that's
completely different
joey you still dating that mulan yeah
and you're still
you're not saying nothing negative
that's what people don't understand
that's a joke like wait i'd still say to
you what's going on you still dating
that jew bro no i dumped that piece of
[__] i'm dating this mexican chick now
she feels so positive so far
you said that right now
you get now you get outcasted you get
destroyed that's how it was nick you
still dating that cuban trick yeah yeah
[__] you like that little speaker
you like that puerto rican ass i know
and you'll tell me right to my face let
me tell you something joey i don't know
what i like more
the [__] [__] or the food right i
gained 18 pounds in two weeks
yeah but you know what i go to the
mother's house they feed me they call me
hermano
i'm drinking with them they invited me
to a party in miami they paid for the
tickets these people [__] crazy
here's the here's the ironic thing about
that [__] it's really not that racial
it sounds it you know everybody growing
up there you had something to say about
puerto rican they had something to say
about a jew or in black what if i'm the
way i am i say something in the same way
and nobody understands that no they say
oh this guy is uh you know he's a bigot
he's this he's that i'm like you're full
of [__] i'm none of those things but we
all said that because out of curiosity
no one really understood what it was
like but in the end you find out we're
all just [__] people we all kind of
like each other in our own way we just
didn't understand our own little goopy
gods our own cultures you know but once
you got a taste of that you were like oh
[__]
i grew up with the oceans the balzanos i
grew up with the aries the sabatinos the
altmans i grew up everybody had a little
joke about something the irish mix the
shanty irish but at the end of the day
they made it all worked
it was just a joke that's it at the end
of the day
they made it all and that's what do the
right thing the only thing that i like
about was at the end it got a little you
know
to me the only problem i had with that
movie was at the end maybe it got a
little bit
you know a little it got a little hairy
and maybe a little political with the
the guy getting choked out and all that
[__] but for 90 percent of that movie
it's very
very funny
very funny even when they're playing
with the water fountain and what's his
name yeah
god bless you yeah go ahead go ahead go
ahead yeah uh my mom
is so funny jesus christ martin lawrence
has been around
forever i know he's a jimmy smith type
of dude yep how about his [__]
jordans oh your droids are [__] up
110 110 plus tax i mean they were
[__] it was just so funny every
little thing
who's better roger clemens or good and
everything was like it was just so fun
you know
springsteen or prince yeah oh my brother
was funny too you know it's very
frustrating the other dude the other
dude yeah fabric he goes farrakhan fairy
man but my brother was so [__] funny
in that daddy was hot it was good too it
was good too it was i was on the set and
i was just like wow that's how i met
spike and i was like man this is
this is kind of exciting i i didn't know
what it was but you could kind of feel
like you know i had my he brought martin
lawrence over this guy steve white you
know all these dudes and i was like man
i want to be part of this gang this is
this is fun spike you know he had it
going on then and all these you know
rosie perez he found her in the club
with those big nipples and everything
else i mean my god
i was i'm not like a puerto rican one
thank you so tomorrow
that's what i'm thinking about doing
nickname tomorrow what are you doing
yeah that was with my daughter at the
park over here and i was walking and i
saw a
beginning acting class
for older adults
you
yeah beginning acting class for all the
adults i called the number they said
show up you gotta commit to eight weeks
sign some paperwork and you're in the
class i'm thinking of going to my 11
o'clock really
why not
yeah no pressure acting class this is
because i want to do it not because i
have to be have you ever taken an acting
class absolutely oh okay absolutely yeah
that's here you have to i i did the
whole circuit the casting director the
vana chubby the other chick
and then one day i did a movie with
coburn
and he's like stop doing it so who's
taking the who's doing this class i have
no idea i don't want to give a [__]
right i don't give a [__]
what listen you always learn something
and you exercise the muscle that's right
and everybody complains there's no work
oh exercise or muscle generate the work
yeah and you never know what's going to
happen
no you don't know you know
everything leads to something we always
every time you and i speak on the phone
with his laps but there's three minutes
or four minutes of the conversation that
how long how much longer can this last
we're not working you know
and every offer that does come in is is
you can't even leave the house for that
yeah you got to bring your own shoes
your own suit they want you to fly
yourself in
put up your own hotel visa and we're
screaming
and actually i'm doing this for a long
time you're in the union 30 years 30
years in the union 20 [__] years
how could this be possible you know that
we have to pay
for our own what are you looking at you
keep going with t-shirts no i'm just
looking in the middle don't worry all
right
i'm looking at this [__]
i'm thinking about this uh what was the
movie i did with the narrow one oh my
gosh my drugs match grudge man and i've
said it a thousand times i had to fly
myself in yeah i know delta the new
halloween there's the same thing with
blue bloods i was doing three years four
years can't [__] believe it that
you've been paying
uh union dues and you paid another point
and a half at the end of the year and
now they won't even pay for your [__]
plane ticket hey listen i did 40
episodes guest starring how is that a
guest star
40 flight yeah about 40 episodes 35
flights yeah i have to come off the
plane do my [__] memorize my [__] on the
plane rehearsal because i knew i wasn't
going to get many takes
boom knock it out and then get back on
the plane the kid kid i worked with used
to go how do you do it i go i do it i go
you know i just like this part of the
it's part of the home i i never thought
i could do [__] like that you know i'd
be on a plane talking to myself people
would be looking at me
one time i was in somebody who was are
you okay yeah i'm just i'm memorizing
lines right oh oh what are you doing
well
meanwhile they're [__] googling you
while they sit next to you i'm a
pediatrician
pediatrician yeah yeah
whatever but i mean that's the world we
live in you know now you're a guest star
you're a guest star for 100 episodes and
they get away with it
unbelievable you believe that
and they won't tell you like at least
tell me yeah if you're gonna put me in
eight so i'm in an apartment here they
say you know like this they don't tell
you no
people i tell you this and we're not
griping you know we just want to keep
you informed at home that i never want
you to think when you see these actors
tell you these men get
these mid-range guys you see you think
we're making millions no you're not
you're [__] fighting for your life
anymore that's it and the unions cut you
to your cup you throw your own union
yeah who you [__] pay i know i know
it's like a lot of money not a little
bit of money no a lot
of money wants to hire me for a movie in
canada and he goes well it's a disney
movie they're making a remake
an old you know uh
what i forget the movie but they don't
even want to like you know they don't
want to pay and then there's another
thing my brother's doing in europe he's
like i don't know i gotta see if they'll
let us hire another american actor
well they're hiring you why can't they
hire one more because of the union you
know i
like i'm [__] believable i mean you
can't make a living
you know i'm actually gonna work with
spike again i think i haven't worked you
know i started out with spiders it's
funny the people you start out with you
know like the crampton says the people
you meet on the way up you're going to
meet the same people on the way down and
it's like full circle started out with
you know abrams and now i'm like 30
years later i'm with these people uh you
know and you know i started out with
spike now man spike calls me up what's
up man it's tough out there i'm like
yeah yeah
i go i feel you man i hear you i got you
i got you i go yeah right i'm glad
somebody's got me because
you feel very alone in this business
people don't know they just know oh i i
love your show i love you on the show
i'm not on the show no but i saw you i
know you saw me
but it's a re-run you
know no no no but that's what your life
becomes you become like a [__] rerun
like you know what are you doing i let
people that go what are you doing like
you died like you passed away
you okay i haven't seen you know you
mean you haven't seen you don't know me
you don't [__] know me my people say
i love you i love you man i love you how
could you love me you don't know me
how do you know you love me
how the [__] do you know you love me
that's true i mean you don't [__]
love me you'd say you love me that's
what i love about this town man love you
baby love you
you know where you been yeah you know
i'm like where i've been i'm here what
do you mean where you been
i'm working i'm working i'm working i'm
working here [__] movies that only
get released i know i did about eight
you know [__] 55 independent movies
that no one will ever see
these [__] movies i don't even wanna
i just go in and just go yeah pay me
cash we were having a conversation about
that
two weeks ago with chris delia that
these independent movies they started
out [__] tremendous
and they want to bust too
they when i first moved here in 98
to get an independent film dog you had
to kill 20 people
and then you gotten one and nothing
happened
and you got in the second one and
nothing happened then they call you with
the festival [__] those are the best
ones when they call you all right one
down the corner let me see if i'm in
town i can't cancel
but then there's some people who say hey
guess what
we're in the
iowa springs
film festival yeah yeah can you fly
yourself can you come
sunday you're like are you [__] crazy
yeah you don't want to spend a weekend
in iowa i love iowa but i'm not going
out there for a film festival stand
around and play jolly celebrity
while people point at me and go you were
great in the film oh my goodness
great things are going to happen for you
sure right
keep saying that for yourself
ain't that gonna happen what do you do
for a living i'm a plumber what are you
gonna do give me an ad on your network
what do you do
it's really and you don't want to look
at it that way when people contact you
now
you look at it and you go so what's the
deal right and they tell you go let me
think about it for a day i got to know
why i want to be on youtube
exactly and they're like excuse me and
you're like
you just told me you got a cousin who
works at cbs that means i got dick
that means i got dick by the time we
shoot this there's no cousin
and next thing you know you're calling
me up to see if my agent could call up
fx
and selling this piece of [__] with this
lighting guy that didn't have no light
bulbs look at me i'm darker than ever
i've been this dark in 20 [__] years
look at me yeah you know no no it's a
[__] joke i just did a [__] dog
movie it was hilarious with [__] dogs
and dolph lundgren
what a [__] guy he was
nice guy but [__] let me tell you
something you don't know where you're
going [__] i'm interacting with
people you just go how did i wind up
here and we're trying to rehearse the
scene he's like
stuff i said
we gotta rehearse
gotta rehearse stuff
oh okay okay you are funny you are a
funny guy i said yeah
i'm all right never mind funny let's
just rehearse so
i could get my [__] line in
let me get my [__] line in you know
what i mean
doing the [__] movie with dogs and
the dog train is like okay don't make
any noise when the dogs are on the set
and i said yeah it's all about the
[__] dogs now thank you let me tell
you something
again
i did six movies
for disney with a [__] dog yeah you
did a bunch of those right dean can you
gary valentine i'd listen i would never
volunteer for those like i said they
they sell i guess they sell these they
sell but you got a movie about dogs
here's the story that people don't
[__] know okay let me tell you again
this is a podcast and i'm not writing
nobody out i'm just informing the
podcast the [__] consumer what's
really crackalackin
like we discussed so you have a scale
film and then you have a film 100 hours
a day
what these people do is they try to sell
you 100 hours a day so what do you think
happens and i i'm really sorry to say it
this way when you're in the hallowed day
movie and there's dogs involved and cats
and snakes
listen to me that's gonna be a long
[__] day
because these guys didn't make it out of
the top of that class
when you work on a [__] real disney
movie
scale plus 10
your own closet clothing meals every
three hours
great script great actors a few from
yesteryear and a few from today to sell
the film on abc [__] family right you
know it's you got a [__] canine
that's smart
you gotta laugh you gotta oh yeah you
got these little lounges
yeah they're hungry movies these dogs
were hit by a car and they trained them
but i don't want to be there maybe they
buy a car two years ago yeah you wanna
put me on this set to run around with a
[__] bow in my mouth give me a
[__] break yeah they give them
cookies these dogs don't respond it's
[__] bad the cats are bad i know i
went through hell on those dog movies
remember that all those days when you
see an animal in the script
that's a 14 hour
that's a 14-hour day because whatever
that was add the dog time and the dogs
will only be there for eight hours right
so what you do is you shoot all the
scenes with the dog
doing
all the [__] you can
and then once you shoot all those things
you cut the animal and then you shoot
your scenes like if the dog was there
so we're still in the room talking and
they're shooting a dog right we're still
having the dialogue from our scene
we shoot all those things go boy go get
him he's a crook bite him all that [__]
right then later on they cut the dog and
we do all our things they do our shots
right they already got the coverage on
the dog right but the dog gets tired
mm-hmm after an hour and a half he's
like a human being you need to [__]
breathe yeah the dog has better working
conditions yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the dog
no there's a game and an animal on the
set i'm sure
peter when you have a movie with an
animal you got a deuce out
to some fat [__] like me to come on your
set and tell you excuse me
the animals it's time they go for a walk
and eat now
yeah yeah then they come in with the
kids too
the kids got to work a certain amount of
time they got to get school time they
want to get breaks i saw that so they'll
come right in with the kids and cut in
and go hey he's got to go to school
class for two hours for a couple hours
we shoot around this scene right then
they come back and finish out their
[__] day no i know
[Music]
pretty that's why whenever you shoot and
they have kids in the script people get
[__]
this better be a good bull idea or tim
allen better be here yeah you need
somebody in charge somebody that makes
it yeah but if you got a free-for-all
and an indie with these
kind of you know uh circumstances you
get [__]
[__] up like the other guy was working
what he would show up and sit there for
12 hours i said i'm not coming
call me when you're ready
this other [__] guy could be here i
was here for seven hours so that's you
i'm i'm not i'm not sitting here for
seven i'll go insane you know i mean one
night i just i just went home it was
like i was there all night i said
i'm i'm so angry think guys you want to
go home you want to go home listen yeah
i'm i don't want to go home i'm going
home
i'm [__] going home i'm going to
denny's right now it's five o'clock in
the morning
[__] it
matt denny's eating a [__] breakfast
i'm angry you know doing it doing a dog
movie i'm like you know you don't want
to wind up like this [__]
it's like i was playing a mad scientist
a few weeks ago on a sunday in some
[__] warehouse something that sounds
like fun yeah it was kind of funny i
made something out of it but i was
acting with you know you're acting with
all these [__] people you what's your
man science's name huh
what was the mad scientist name oh my
name yeah i can't even [__] remember
now but it was it was fun he don't want
to remember what i don't want to
remember
the guy just gave me an envelope and i
just said that's it
you know i mean it was a day's pay
at least i got to laugh a little bit you
had to talk like it sounds like fun kind
of was but you wanna you wanna do like
more prestigious jobs yeah but you wanna
do something more you know worth what
you've
put in you know you don't work 30 years
and then you
you know you're picking up mission mosh
it's
if you come to me today ain't going on a
nice movie
it's gonna pay your scale joey listen
i'm gonna shoot you in another
you're not gonna get no overtime i'm
gonna pay your scale
four hours couple scenes you get shot
maybe four or five days
where's your shoot
ventura come in
something what are we doing with the
thing
to be strictly honest with you you know
that company
they gotta put the [__] movie on
there
we're gonna go straight to that you get
some yearly residual and that's
everybody's happy
if it's gonna be fun i know the director
yeah
everything's good you don't mind and the
material ain't bad yeah you feel like
all right i got a good workout it was
actually like it you felt like you did
something rather than just
now it just became like about you know
making money here and there just but you
know at least with that you go all right
at least i
this could be something it could be
decent you know what i mean you know
every now and then you need to do
something for your soul that you go all
right at least i tried
yeah this was fun you know what it was
for me the last couple years when i did
those two episodes of married
i just went nuts for ifc
they had nobody on there so i could do
whatever the [__] i want that's good the
other day when i was in [__]
pittsburgh
which if it came to the shows thank you
very much you guys are [__]
tremendous
some guy came up to me he goes
i never saw you to an episode of man
when you were doing coke off the table
and you said something about him
and he goes after that i went nut that
was one of the fun you know i'm saying
like i could let loose by that time i
knew how to let loose right the longest
shot i didn't know how to let loose yet
i didn't know the responsibilities of of
letting yeah well a long shot there was
a lot of people a lot of people and
maybe you hadn't done that many movies
not like that not like that no i was
fresh off like spiderman too yeah and
taxi i could tell you were in the longer
short you were kind of like you were out
of your element you weren't like
absolutely me two weeks i had been doing
a lot of stuff before that so when i got
an opportunity to do like a comedy
i just you know i i did my work other
than breaking my foot
but i i was making the most i was gonna
make the most out of that experience and
then you know adam made it a better part
for me as it went along but i i knew i
kind of had an approach and then i saw
what what he was doing but i think for
you it was a newer
it was like it was a big scene it was a
macroeconomic
it's not me and nick
it's nine people you had to come in with
a camera you had to come in there
yeah and you had a rocket because there
was 85 000 guys in there but if you
could
you know if you if you have an approach
you have a good character the good thing
about a guy like adam is he let people
you know he let there was room to shine
believe it or not there was i i thought
you know but i think for new for you i
think
you had a great time but i think was
also it was it was a new experience for
you yeah no no it was it was like that
one day we got wrapped remember we got
wrapped
and you called me like nick we got
[__] rap now they're calling us back
yeah no no no no that's why i couldn't
deal with it and then you go what are we
doing i go well i gotta go back
they unwrapped us
and you were like [__] it i'm not going
back i said
i said i know but they unwrapped us i
said you know i
the right thing to do was to go back
because you know and then i got back
then they wrapped me again
so i mean i understood where you were
coming from but you know it was
it was a good chance yeah
you know i just didn't like that i
didn't like there was a lot of whatever
but i had a great experience
i mean adam treated everybody good
i mean there's no two ways that was
that the time in santa fe was great i
missed him the other day at the comedy
store i missed him by two minutes really
i walked back then he goes you know what
he saw he goes he said you were on the
lineup and he giggled he he giggled oh
he liked you yes i'm not yeah no i don't
like you
i thought you were italian it was funny
when i first [__] saw it i still
remember the first
van ride home that
that thursday night from the high school
do you remember it was me and you and we
were at the high school first oh yeah
the food truck was there yeah we ate and
it was me you and the one producer in
the van
the italian guy with the kid
the real cool not the dude with the
[__] brother
the cool dude with the with the kid that
was about 16
and one weekend that weekend
he left but left his 16 year old kid
and i went down to the pool with
bosworth
and i saw the kid and the kid jumped in
the pool he was shy and i talked to the
kid and
we went nate with the kid and the kid
was a great kid you know i'm like where
is that
he goes well he wanted me to go back
with him what was i going to do 10 l.a
for the weekend yeah i'd rather stay
here with you guys so we had a great
time
kent ended up going coming to see me at
the laugh factory
yeah
when he turned 19. you know who it is it
was me you and that producer
in the van that thursday night
uh god rest or so your mom was sick the
first time she had a heart attack yeah
we were going back you were worried
we were going back to the hotel yeah
adam was good guys that's when i met you
we react on the van we giggled
something we had somebody in common
i forget who it was and then
then that
weekend i was by the pool and i'm
sitting there with bosworth and he's
taking me into murky waters of the nfl
my jaw
is in the jacuzzi and you know like as a
sports enthusiast you really think you
know [__] about sports and you don't
know dick till you talk to bosworth
and the hard on they had for him and how
they took his [__]
bonus check every weekend as a fine
because he didn't tuck in his shirt
just he had me that sunday that my head
was spreading oh really like they took
his house psychotherapy in hawaii
yeah then did you see they do it 30 30
30 30 on him did you watch it
very good yeah and that's it he had a
nervous breakdown he had to leave
seattle and i mean it was [__] deep
you know yeah and he you grew up
thinking these guys lived the [__]
life for riley
and they really liked that in the nfl
and it hasn't been a [__] long time
so yeah i mean that was interesting it
was interesting but that sunday night
your family wasn't down there yet right
so i'm walking past i think and i hear
you [__] you and i'm like let me go talk
to this guy
i knock on your door
you just barely open the door you're on
the [__] two little cedar couch the
balcony door was open oh the balcony and
you're up there [__] yelling at the
tv what's going on there the [__]
yankees they got a minute
and you're yelling and i'm loving it i
haven't seen that type of behavior yeah
in 20 years now there's fakers
when there's women around there are
fakers
you know characters what you do when
there's nobody watching right right i
can hear you yelling from the [__]
pool
i'm like why is he [__] yelling
and that was just brilliant i went
upstairs and saw the yeah you remember
that huh like a [__] it was yesterday i
remember like a [__] bull oh yeah no
i've had people you know they walk in
the house and walk out that's the show
yeah
no you're right because that's right
there's an episode
nine innings with nick that's the name
of it there's no sound
no sound on the tv on the tv but you
could shoot
starting right now like this guy like
yeah well look at this [__] dude here
he's one for [__] two
and this [__] bases are loaded and
this [__] guy hasn't hit nothing in
ten [__] days and they put him in and
they got this other mulligan what's his
name
the dominican kid whatever by the way i
gotta tell you something last night i'm
sitting by the computer i get home i
take a nap
i get back up i'm still [__] up from
the flight back from pittsburgh which
again
i had a great time what a beautiful
[__] city
what a beautiful [__] city it's a
good city i love that city i've always
loved that city
it's always a pleasure going there the
flight everything
can we talk about the food
the food's delicious anyway mine your
business
what food i had chinese i'm not just
gonna talk about chinese three days in a
row delivery
that old-school chinese
listen poor fried rice i didn't i
explored outside the realm it was just
it was no bueno and i stuck to what i
know
there's three things you get if those
things suck you don't call me one time
so not even no one wants to drink one
ton soup but i gotta go on a plane 18
miles so they give me a half a cup half
of it is drained four fried rice
whatever fried rice two egg rolls two
shrimp egg rolls
and dumplings dumplings the first day i
got pork fried rice a little container
and two egg rolls i ate one egg roll
and i ate the other pork fried rice and
i was ready to throw an egg roll away
and i go you know what
the spirit of [__] satan will punish
me for throwing this [__] away i flew
two i'm never gonna eat this again i
kept it in the room
that night i got back from doing comedy
about 11 30.
i [__] ate that [__] egg roll was
kind of stiff
yeah the grease was evaporated it was
delicious
with a tube of hot mustard on it sure
with a [__] water because i you know
me i can't be drinking that soda no i'm
trying to be good and [__] like that
so yeah i ate chinese food i had
breakfast i kept it normal
and at night i had avocados and chicken
avocado is good i'm trying to keep it
together little by little you know what
i'm saying yeah there's nothing wrong
with avocado sounds interesting as [__]
but what i was going to tell you was
what what oh oh [__]
so i go on facebook and i try to answer
a few messages and i go on twitter
because i don't take the computer on the
road with me no more
so i don't want to say nothing i'm doing
comment okay if i do anything it's
writing a joke yeah i don't even want to
go
up and down yet right
so i [__] i turned on the computer
last night
and who do i see
after 15 years
are you ready lisa
no
louis hernandez
aka louis the [__]
he was the first dominican kid that
moved into my name but 1974. really this
neighborhood wasn't racist
but they didn't know louis louie had an
afro right so in their mind he was black
so behind his back they called him louie
the [__] and then one day they just
started calling him louis [__] to his
face and he would keep saying i'm not
black
it was hysterical i know that's funny he
was dynamite and you know who else was
in that picture oh
all i could say is his first name
gerard
gerrard
me and there was a kid sabatina who i
grew up with who i've spoken about in
the podcast
there was like four or five cats acha
penti
a kid named aponti and [__] named
gerard is always like we had a guy in
our neighborhood dried and he was like a
scary [__] dude well this dude was
scary beautiful
italian man i even called my wife and
because his
goomba is my daughter's godfather yeah
they're the same blood i go come here
for a second
you think mercy's godfather is a good
looking man
take a look at this side of the family
boy i was like jesus christ
what happened to him how come he's not
on tv i go
he became a doctor yeah but when that
kid was 16 17 nick he was fierce
he was my straight man when i used to
try to roll gay guys
we were they weren't really gay they
were guys that came over from the city
to get that dick sucked in jersey god so
this guy was a good looking dude he was
the bait out there
we put him up there like a soldier nick
and cars will pull up next to him wow
you're beautiful
you want to go on a date and go pull
over
and then when he'd get out of the car
walk him into the park and we jumped and
dude really oh my god we were young and
stupid dog can you imagine
well things that could have happened
it's a different different time being
him went out like two months we were
evil
we used to go to this bar
and he was such a good looking dude bro
that he would just lord chick said we
were in high school
we were juniors
and nobody really knew him and i hung
out together
his father was italian
but he made the best chili in rice
you ever had in your life chilean rice
chili with white rice on the side you
could either have it without the rice he
told me one time have it with the rice
you don't like it better i'm cute and i
like big i like you it's the same
[__] thing yeah every time i go over
that because he would call me and go my
dad made chili come over
so whenever i would go over there we i'd
go over there eat and while i was over
there he taught me
who we were going to pinch that night
and he was really good looking so we
always rob some chick's house right he
was always robbing some chick that was
26 or 27 times and this guy became a
doctor yeah
wow
it took him like 49 [__] years to get
his degree don't get me wrong yeah
yeah he's all those dudes yeah but he's
still straight up i still people say he
sends his love to me i loved him dearly
i loved his sister daily
his father was my goomba each he got me
out of a couple messes growing up and
[__]
so i would go over there and eat the
chili and [__] but i remember oh my god
this me and this kid used to do some
creepy [__]
so he hooked up with this stripper
and he told me that he we were a high
school dog
he was 17
and she he told me that he would she
would bring him over the house at like
11 o'clock at night he was getting booty
calls in 19 [__] 80 already
oh this guy he was she was 26 he was 16.
he's a stud huh and he would walk to a
house how tall was he
five nine five ten defend
look like a [__] mile like there was
three or four those italian dudes that
had that different italian look to him
right they didn't look italian and hard
right they were italian and beautiful
they just had they looked like robert
redford but they had brunette hair i
grew up with like three of those
[__] that they were unstoppable
[__]
yeah
it's unbelievable but this dude set up
this check he told me
she's a stripper
she like why did you meet her he was
admitted at a bar and then she invited
me out she's 26.
he goes i [__] like 10 times
i know exactly where the jewelry is
where her money is
the whole [__] thing oh boy
so on a tuesday night like 11 he picked
me up in his father's car
we went over there that was the lookout
and i heard him kick in the [__]
window
i counted the ten i didn't see nothing
and all of a sudden he comes running out
with a bag he gets in the car we go for
a [__] ride
and he found cash not much we each got
like 200 a piece
which
1980s then we got a little jewelry but
yeah that's a lot in
he said [__] i couldn't find the main
thing what was he looking for a hand
a handshake had a hand
that had rings
oh diamond rings sapphire you know she
had the whole [__] thing he cased it
out he had the whole [__] diamond eye
this guy this guy
this guy was one of my favorite partners
of all time and i always knew
he wasn't a bad kid he was knocking at
me
was oh yeah i tried to protect him as
much as i could but i also knew his dick
got hard doing this
there's certain people that you grew up
with that you know they're not bad
people yeah but they get a rush
yes
doing a certain thing yeah he got a rush
from that and i had like two or three of
those in my life that came to me and
said listen
i don't really want to do this but i
want to do this with you
i want to [__] go have a good time
one time you know what i'm saying
and that was crazy he was one of those
guys until today
he still sends love
like i have a mutual friend that really
sees him he always goes hey
g sends his love he's still good looking
oh my god i don't know he's my age now
but in this picture he was it was him
sabz
he was like yes
they were
they were at a baseball tournament in
high school there were young kids
just amazing memories man with those
guys it's fair it's amazing how fast
your life goes right man lately i've
been thinking about a lot and i'm just
thinking like wow
it's [__] not that it's over but you
know
it is kind of and the way it is because
you go [__] man
i'm 55 you know like what al says in
that movie you know scarf is you got a
bag you got a belly you know it says it
but it's kind of true because you look
in the mirror you see your [__] belly
and you see this and
you're starting to feel your skin a
little bit not as tight you're at the
light huh you ever been a light mind in
your own [__] business yeah and you
look over to your right hand side yeah
and there's a couple
about 18 and a half yeah
and then walking home hand in hand yeah
they're going home to do homework for
about two minutes yeah then he's gonna
rip off her [__] pants right and [__]
until the end yeah and listen you snap
out of this dream and you know
that's never going to happen to me again
like i'm never going to fall in love
again yep not going to make out anymore
i'm not going to know the beginning of i
mean i love my wife we still yeah
you know you make out that's good i'm
talking about
uh
we're never gonna be at that place where
we meet a girl for the first time and
take it to a movie no the magic and the
dinners yeah you know bringing the
flowers and falling in love that's
[__] magic you know what i mean
that's that's it yeah it's gone five
that sets in already yeah i'll be 55 in
february
god take me there you're with me
you have to realize these things aren't
going to happen again in your life
you know you you go to these jiu jitsu
classes and sometimes i get frustrated
and i'm like wait a second
how am i going to do a [__] z guard
you know you got to reach down and pull
yourself i'm 200 pounds
you know but i go i show up when i do
what i [__] could do and when i
wrestle young kids and i get frustrated
but at least i'm exercising which is
what keeps you alive that's why i dress
up more every now and then you know i
put a put my offers together this and
that it's not that i'm trying to be
young but just
just to [__] feel good you know what
i mean just to feel like yeah i still i
got something i ain't got what you know
i still got something
i gotta have some edge i gotta find some
way to [__] get off but what would
listen what do you
i mean what do uh
you what would be the life for you right
now to have a 22 year old no i didn't
mean to [__] no no i'm not even
saying that yeah i'm just saying i
walked in my son's room the other day
and he was home from college and
some
good looking broad was in there with an
earring and a nose and she was braiding
his hair and i said oh hi
she was like hi
i was like i was like looking i was like
i look at this [__] this this is it this
is you know
young people you know we're not that
no yeah just not that
you know you're not you're not like
completely over the hill but
you know
but we are all over there yeah listen
when you go to a show i know and you
look around and you see a guy like me or
you
you go
especially if you're a 20 year old yeah
what do they want with me no no no you
have to be honest with yourself
you know what i see in the mirror is com
not what people are saying people adding
10 years to this i know and it's not
like i'm trying to win a beauty contest
i couldn't win a beauty contest when i
was 21. i'm not gonna win a beauty
contest now at 50 [__] four so yeah
it uh you accept a lot of things
that that one was really shocking i just
can't believe it went so fast to be
honest i'm just like torturing this
[__] kid lee
take care of this league don't miss a
day lee
if i get any advice for anybody listen
don't miss a day
don't miss a day i missed
30 years of days
by doing drugs and [__] around i
missed 25 years of days
and i wish i could get half of them back
yeah
well that's the problem if you spend
half your life stoned sitting around
getting high walking
jesus christ guys i know i lie not to
you it goes by no you're 20 19.
next thing you know you're 23 and you're
graduating 24 you get the dream job and
guess what next thing you know you're
30. i lived in my 30s and then you're 34
and then all of a sudden 38 creeps on
you and you have a nervous breakdown
because you're two you're 40 in two
years it happened to me but you start
writing and confusing yourself and
saying 40 is the new 30
and all the [__] that goes with it
and then you know what man it's not you
never fall apart
if you take care of yourself
you will not fall apart you gotta stay
in shape too and you try to listen when
i did the longest yard from that point
on i got after the longest y'all i
gained another 40. i was so used to
eating pastrami sandwiches wow for my
third breakfast the longest shot i mean
you know you know how much i ate on that
[__] set yeah we were waiting like
seven years we ain't we're good man we
were eating like [__] yeah adam
fetters good savages savages those
[__]
buffalo burgers at the uh hotel i didn't
touch those no no i touched the kid's
spaghetti and me i saw uh irving i saw a
man over the fight i told you picked me
up gave me a big ass hug he was hugging
me for so long michael urban we're
sitting in the dining area one night
it's a little room maybe seats uh 30
tables maybe 25 tables
we're about three weeks into the longest
shot it's a friday night
we have saturday and sunday off adam has
to go do something
and that friday night i decided to go
downstairs and have macaroni and cheese
from the kids manually
at the hotel center hotel yeah
lee you have no idea
do i ever call you up and say i just had
kids macaroni and cheese from something
not usually your mind would blow up
when it and here's the beauty of it
it's the kid's menu yeah yeah
that's the scary thing this is what i
ate for two weeks
i couldn't wait to get back to the hotel
room and listen there was no reason for
because i always got vulnerable on that
[__] set especially in santa fe we
had the smoothies we had the prosciutto
we had the [__] ham the wet mutts
but lee i couldn't wait to get to the
hotel
they already knew when i'd walk in the
kitchen was right there when you walk
into the desk the kitchen was right
there and i go throw the order in and i
go to my room take a shower
or smoke and join the balcony
come in put my shorts on i go downstairs
and then have a table for me
with the kids macaroni and cheese
manja baby with a piece of bread that
was good [__] glee tremendous good [__]
your mind was blood you might you
wouldn't need anything else
the kids mac and cheese in the morning
they had a little breakfast for you yeah
you started the morning off daily with a
nice coffee
nice coffee two eggs sunny side up
tons of bacon
tons of [__] sausage strips and tons
of bread
then you got in the van
okay lee you went to
the [__] set
you went into tattoos
and then you put your equipment on and
then from there they would say to you
go eat
so 45 minutes later lee you were back in
the child room with eggs sausages polish
sausage pancakes french toast whipped
cream waffles cherries
bananas protein shakes lee you like what
is it i just had oh yeah
i just had a new uh
wardrobe every week because oh my god i
did they they bought extend the clothes
for me
now we ate good we drank good everything
you know what that's like italy and that
your call is at eight right but at seven
you're already eating like a doctor like
you're like yeah i go to prison and do
life after this meal
but it don't end you're gonna go on the
set now is everyone doing it to it no no
people are adhering to their diets
everybody's doing everybody's smoking
briefing i never knew like the producers
were like you know there's no [__]
ideally then we went to the [__] set
and there was a room tell them how big
the room was with benches it looked like
a prison cafeteria huge and it had
tables upon tables of cakes
i still never forget the night with lobo
when they made me and lobo work towards
the end as a goof
it just was a goof they weren't gonna
use another [__] it was so bad they put
a picture of i was supposed to be a
tattoo artist a lobo was a tattoo artist
of me
and he put a picture of what was the
chick
that we goofed on
the view
the chick that's a comedian abel
enjoyed beyonce joe baja remember that
he like joined because he says that her
name is right so in those scenes they
put a tattoo on me well that night it
was me
lobo
i think michael irvin has shot a scene
early and a few other people
and it was a [__] chocolate fountain
that were you there that no i wasn't in
that chocolate fountain
this is at the end of the shoot like we
haven't eaten enough
like we haven't eaten like [__] pigs
enough
and this is week
16.
there's nobody left in this movie shoot
it was me and lobo that they just had us
torturing us what was that about
was it something they added or it was
just that they were just keeping us dead
though they were like three night shoots
and it was me and lobo and this song in
l.a yeah at fox studios uh paramount we
went over there the one night our call
was at four
they put makeup
[Music]
you know yeah put your shoulder pads on
do this do that
ah we're gonna break for dinner
really
we just [__] got here
yeah but they were here shooting
exteriors of planets and [__]
you [__]
we broke for dinner we ate and we sat
around for another hour
then they put me and lobo in a cell
and we do eight things or something and
they go cut
all right
that's martini rap and we're like
really
you dirty [__]
and then the next night we came in
i didn't know this and it was a scene
where lobo was giving me a tattoo
and i find out he [__] up he doesn't
put joy bae home like that what do you
put abe lincoln or somebody somebody
different
he [__] up
he put oprah or something yeah he put
oprah they never used any of that no it
was pure garbage yeah
it was pure garbage
i knew as they were shooting that this
is a [__] straw i was right at first
they're like yeah adam wants to add all
these scenes with you and lobo
and then they tried to reshoot the scene
where
we throw the toilet paper which we just
could not pull it off
which one was the scene when we scored
the winning touchdown we're all supposed
to be hurt i get knocked out
goldberg
uh somebody else and somebody else ali
we're all in the hospital
and we're if you watch the original when
they scored the last touchdown oh we're
in the hospital oh you guys are in the
hospital throwing toilet paper [__]
picking up a nurse
and at this point we it was me goldberg
lobo no no and uh
rob schneider played the nurse
so i never used it no we raped it
oh [__] supposedly you see us throwing
their shoes off
yeah they weren't gonna use that they're
not gonna use that no that was all added
footage and there was something that's
the director's cut
yeah yeah it was all [__] they were
not they just kept us there and our
calls were at four
and they cut us at exactly 11 o'clock
all right cut my team what the [__]
why did we even do this we're not gonna
shoot from this like nah nah nah we're
just gonna almost everything i did in
them it was practice made it almost
everything except the one
scene with uh chris rock and adam at the
beginning it was in one cut and it was
very very funny
where i did the push-ups right before
you know they had the whole big gun fire
at the in the mess hall
and adam looks at me and i look at him
and i go
brooklyn [__]
and it was very funny and then i think
it was like it almost like took away
from adam and chris's opening and they
should have left it that was the one
thing they didn't leave and
they should have [__] left that but
it was very funny i remember because i
just like i just did these five push-ups
and then
then he's like yes or what and i go
brooklyn
[__] something like that it was really
[__] funny it was really [__]
funny but most of the [__] all made it
most of it i mean you know you watch a
film as a child
you watch a film as an adult it's on
every week and then you and then you get
in the film and now you watch it years
later and you see those takes
and you go you know what those tanks
weren't dick
it's what we were doing in between those
tanks oh yeah shot yeah and said [__]
the movie let these guys go
like that my memorable thing on that
movie
was the day we ate the cranberry sauce
and the chicken that was
for you definitely for me i never
laughed that hard in my life if you
think i was laughing with the little
rascals and chusby usb
oh he's funny
that was the week
okay let me tell you something you know
me lately he's been around me for five
years six years if i tell you that at
that point
every weed i had
was good
but for some reason
that particular week of the longest yard
and i still remember who called me and
said joey i know you're a long time i
know you like marijuana
do you have eight hundred dollars
and i know what's 800 i was gonna get me
and he goes joey i'll come over and
bring a sample
but i tell you what i got three pounds
left
and i'm gonna bring a sample to another
guy when you see this and smoke this
you're gonna want this
i said okay
he brought me maybe two grams of this
[__]
i smoked a skinny joint
and i almost passed out this was the
next level
at that point whenever i was smoking up
to 2004 was good when i got to
albuquerque i had that blueberry hill
that was good that got me high when i
was a kid i used to smoke chocolate tie
in new york from harlem from the [__]
rastafarians whatever from jamaica that
was the [__] that killed mcdaddy
but this weed took me to the next level
so when he told me 800
for the number he wanted me there was
only one man i had the money at the
house
so i told the guy i said you know what
show up with two of them tomorrow i
showed up with two out of three the next
day i paid them the next day i went in
there and i went to a certain black dude
that was all i set
and i said here smoke a joint of this
and the next day he came up to me goes
what's the number on that
and i said what an ounce and he goes no
a pound [__]
and i said give me like 12. 12 watt
pounds 1200 and he goes you know what
give him 1200.
and i said it's in the trunk of the
[__] car
and i said i'll get you another one he
goes give me another 1200. that's how
fast it went it was a miracle this weed
was tremendous
it [__] you up what'd you feel
you just felt [__] stoned like goofy
yeah for 45 minutes you would lose you
know conscious like you couldn't focus
on your words and [__] you were just
smoking while you were working oh please
we smoked it
a lot of people were high in that movie
oh
so here's what happened not me
that
the day that we shoot that scene
with the turkey and the cranberry sauce
you were laughing a lot of the chicken
yeah the chicken the chicken the crab
maybe something that was the day he was
you on this oh and now here's the funny
thing about it there was a group of kids
there
that maury povich had brought on the
show
because he was friends with goldberg
but this was also ironically
the day i show up with two pounds of his
weed on the set
this guy took it in his trailer started
rolling up [__] blunts and started
passing them out
we smoked this [__]
and i'll tell you what i was never so
hungry in my life
so we're sitting at this table
and i'll never forget the cranberry
sauce had to be 10 inches from me
unless done on the cranberry sauce and
also somebody else died on the cranberry
sauce because eight of us at that table
had smoked that [__]
so everybody was [__] hungry you
don't remember they got mad because we
kept eating the chicken and the
cranberry sauce they had to go get more
and they finally goes guys enough
there's no more left we have cranberries
that was why we're going nuts because we
were stoned on the same weed and this
weed was so [__] strong and so next
level [__] weed
like everyone every eight months you
smoke a weed that you're like jesus
christ yeah i'm going to stall them i'm
buying the rest of this and i'm putting
in the safe
because this is why i'm going to be
smoking when that missile the korean
sends over yeah this is what i'll be
smoking hey you went to another place
huh oh my god for 45 minutes
then for about 45 for 40 minutes after
that
you would just tie
and then 30 minutes after that you have
to go to your house
and eat everything
or the munchies butter and jellies or
potato chips what made you hungry for
the fruit to the ice cream anything to
blow pop
the [__] old money got double dogs
yeah yeah you wake up the next morning
and go oh my god i'm constipated right i
had six devil dogs fruit yeah uh
anything you could get your hands on
whatever your wife bought for the kids
right that's a ghana
that goes down the [__] drain [__]
munchies man
that's crazy i loved
like i don't know i always felt [__]
up about alcohol
alcohol since day one just wasn't for me
man
my mom had the bar
i would try from time to time my mom
would put my bib
my my what's that [__] the pacifier and
blackberry brandy when i was a kid that
aftertaste
of whatever uh
i have a friend that drinks vodka
i don't see him much but whenever i do
he drinks vodka and i like one vodka and
orange juice with an extra splash of
orange juice you know what i'm saying
yeah that vodka alcohol flavor
that gets me gagging all the [__]
time it does huh
it's not the best yeah vodka is a little
nail how about rum you like rum
i like dark brown with a coke yeah a
little splash of [__] lemon or cherry
or a lime not bad
i like uh if i had to if i had a gun to
my head a little gin and tonic with a
lime
uh ginger ale with the [__] little
does maybe seven and seven maybe do is
on the rocks i could do with dig with
more rocks i also like an irish cream on
the rocks from time to time the only
time i drink is one cocktail on the
plane but i'll tell you what the last
like six months i don't even take that
cocktail no more you don't drink wine
now and i should
yeah i should drink a nice glass of red
wine red wine is good
yeah i should drink some wine i'm not
i'm slipping thank you for reminding me
i see italians believe in one that's why
you live to 98. gotta have a little even
the big fat ones that eat spaghetti once
a week
pasta all with a nice steak thank you
for showing up with the garlic with the
blue cheese buns don't worry pizza it's
my pleasure
you know i like to cook
oh
you know i didn't make the pizza but
the bombs especially what's going on
with the sauce we need an investor for
this yeah we do need an investment
international investor for next sauce
now this is a uncle nicki's red sauce
the last time he was on here yeah lee
still talks about the sauce it was great
right
it was delicious it was the best sauce
i've had it and it was [__] cold i
know jesus surprised people have been
asking me you know how do i get it and
i'm we need investors we need investors
come through with this source you're
[__] people should put this [__]
you know we should put this [__]
theme you ever hear the old yankee theme
from the 1970s the the song you can
bring it up on the [__] so it pumps
me up the old yankee it's the yankee
yankee theme song that gets me [__]
going
from the 70s get me going get me ready
for tomorrow yeah put it off put it on
just [__] out of respect he's older
than you and he's been listening
to your daddy's pants get the one for
the 1970s yankee theme song i love this
you hear the horns
yeah theme song from the yankee theme
song you're gonna love it
the motherfucker's [__] up
go for it baby
[Music]
i'll tell you this there it is turn it
up
listen to this joey
[Music]
sanchez
carla's clock
roy white
holy cow here we come
the new york yankees tomorrow night the
baby bombers
beat those [__] minnesota twins
otherwise my whole week my whole month's
gonna be [__] jacked
let's do the uh listen to the acoustics
[Music]
hit a trombone
ah this is beautiful it brings me back
to my kid days
i've been watching this i listened to
the whole song on wpix 11
oh man i wouldn't come out of the house
until the game was over
now do you still watch the game on the
new york feed yes
really yeah watch the whole game i'm the
new yorker on the yes channel now
i get the yes channel and then when the
games are on wpix i get the best give me
the playoff picture as it stands right
now for the people that i don't know
what your prediction i want the whole
thing what do you got what you got you
got a dog in this wally well right now
you know tomorrow night the yankees are
playing minnesota for the wild card game
the yankees won the first wild card they
came up two games short of the red sox
so they now have to play the second wild
card team
and they used to just be one wild card
team would that would play the
the wild card team would play the team
with the best record but now because
there's two wild card teams a second
wild card team you have to play this one
stupid uh
russian roulette game so the yankees if
they get through this game tomorrow
night then then we'll play cleveland who
has the best record and then the red sox
will play houston and then over
internationally the dodgers will play
the winner of
wednesday night's nationally wild card
game which is the diamondbacks and the
rockies the winner of that will play the
dodgers who have the best record
in the uh national league you know the
washington nationals will play the cubs
uh any other the other divisions so the
winner of the cub national will probably
play
you know the dodgers will probably get
past the diamondbacks or the rockets i
think the diamondbacks will beat the
rockies
and i think the dodgers will beat them
and then i think the cubs will
upset the uh the nationals always choke
in the playoffs i think the yankees will
beat minnesota tomorrow night and
they'll have a hard time against the the
indians but i still like their chances
and the red sox the astros the astros
are definitely favored but uh i wouldn't
be sh anything could happen
league they went from the national
league to the american league like the
milwaukee brewers just missed out on the
playoffs they were an american league
team who transferred you know switched
leagues
it's weird because the astros were
always a national league team
they belong in a national league and the
brewers
really always belonged in the american
league but i don't know why those teams
switch leaks
but um it's working it's working but the
dream world series would be the yankees
and the dodgers i mean if the yankees
could get that far it would be i mean
they're coming that baby bombers they
had this kid aaron judge who had an
incredible rookie year 52 home runs he's
six foot seven 270 pounds he's and he
can [__] hit man he can really and he
got hot again he had a bad month but he
came out of it and he's [__] his
other kid gary sanchez dominican kid
he's some hit it too but he can't catch
the ball like he's a catch and a ball
goes through his legs he's a little bit
on the dumb side but he can [__] hit
he can really hit this kadidi gregorius
shortstop he's had a great year and
tomorrow night we got a stud young stud
sanchez uh severino going he's a
dominican kid who put it all together so
tomorrow night the key is they got to
just get the lead in the game get the
lead and and don't get behind and uh
he's got a pitch ahead he can't get
behind in the counts if he gets behind
you get [__] hurt because anybody
could lose one game so you know one game
it's a scary uh you know scary thing i'm
going to be on edge tomorrow i got one
game yeah they got one game they gotta
win to to play a series now so the
winner of that game will play cleveland
so you know tomorrow night it's [__]
it's gonna be touchy five o'clock we'll
let five o'clock out here eight o'clock
there
so um you know it's not going to be uh
it's not going to be a comfortable game
because anything could happen in one
[__] game anything you know how many
things could go wrong i was telling my
brother today he goes well
you're really pessimistic you should be
ha i said well i got to think about what
could go wrong or what about what could
go right i said never mind what i know
what could go right it's what could go
wrong because that [__] worries me so
because baseball you know it's little
things that people that are not hardcore
fans don't know they don't really
understand what went wrong a pass ball
an error a stupid [__] play that
could change the whole game
could throw the game into whack or you
know you got to watch out you don't want
to have a crooked inning where you give
up three four runs in an inning if
you're gonna give up a home run
you better make sure nobody's on [__]
base
anyway it's it's you know i i'm looking
forward to the game but i'm not because
you know i know that
if they don't win that game tomorrow
it's going to be yeah i can beat the
dodgers
okay uh
who could beat the dodgers i mean the
the cubs uh
the cubs could beat the dodgers
um
you know uh i don't i don't i don't
think the diamondbacks or the rockies
are gonna beat the dodgers
uh i don't think the nationals will beat
the dodgers i mean the cubs maybe i
think this the dodgers are going to go
to the world series this year i really
do i mean
kershaw he's uh it's about time that he
has a great great postseason and they
got a [__] stud guy there too
bellinger and sega that mean and this
puig is having a better year that the
wild cuban
um i think the dodgers you know this is
the year they get over the hump and go
to the world series possibly win it they
have a good yankees have a great bullpen
too yankees have three great guys so the
bullpens are key too i know red sox is
healing no red socks are plenty
asteroids yeah
they have a great closer that sounds
nice but the red sox yeah well the red
sox they beat the astros and the yankees
yeah so it all starts tomorrow night
tomorrow night uh and wednesday the two
wild card games and then friday and
saturday we'll start the division uh
series so you know let's just hope and
pray after tomorrow night you know
yankee fans have another have something
to look forward to because it's a long
[__] year 162 to be out of one game
it's horrible
[Music]
i'm stoked you stoned stop with that
bottle god damn it i thought it was my
bottle [__] crack and people get
pissed off they jump out of their skin
good to see you my brother
you look good thank you the [__] blue
cheese muffin yeah was just delicious i
couldn't look at it no more
killing me it's like knowing you have
something in the refrigerator and you're
sitting there watching [__] tv it's
11 30. nothing like good food you know
you're getting hungry and hungry about a
goddamn minute you get a nice how's your
child doing in chicago he's doing well
he's doing good yeah he's doing good
justin is it justin you know and the
midwest is a little slow but he likes it
he's writing a lot of [__] rap songs
right now he's got some good [__]
not bad he's getting good at it you know
it's crazy how after i spoke to you told
me i don't know
it's tough for a kid i was writing about
where i was at 19 and
the place i moved and i remember that
the theme was
it was weird
but this is great i'm on my own
nobody [__] knows me i'm meeting
people right people are saying hello to
me
you know it's got to be you're 18. 19.
it's a [__] tremendous great
opportunity
yeah it's a little money in your pocket
you don't want to go to a bar and you
can't do anything anyway you done anyway
you can't drink right so you enjoy the
little things
i'm good with [__] drinking a beer he
went to see hamilton there he went he
went to the fights over there where he
was hanging out with paulie mullinaji
one night
so he's he's experiencing things i'm
like man that's [__] great
he lives in a building like right in the
city yeah a lot of kids you know
you're in there watching game of thrones
and all this [__] this is what you do
yeah it's a little different in the
house but you know what i'm adjusting
see it's just empty well you know he had
such a bit the kids were always there
all the crespi boys at the house was
always filled with
you know uh with all his people and so
now it's like wow everybody's gone
you know my daughter's still there and
she's doing this crew box thing that
she's uh you gotta come out and do a
class it's [__] good in west
hollywood she's an instructor it's
really it's a good workout you bought
you guys you would like the screw boxes
[__] you know you know what this is man
you don't gotta be a boxer look at this
[__] mother dull
oh man he's been watching doing the
patriots there one and three with him
with him watching yeah you don't want to
join another one
he jinxed him you got to watch another
team that you hate from now on and they
believe you like him and go against new
england
that's you got to watch the jets in
miami the jets won two games they said
they're gonna not even win a game
and football is so mediocre now i'm not
a hardcore football guy but you know for
me baseball is everything
i mean i grew up in football i love i
mean i like
it
i love that sunday night family game
i've been watching the quarterly three
four plays
i don't i don't care about what's going
on right now you remember we were kids
this weekend
saturday night this week in football or
something it was beautiful the guy had a
great voice to watch the highlights i
missed the simplicity of sports now it's
24 7.
in your face everybody's got a network
everybody's got analyzation it's the
like when sports there was more to the
imagination
every sport you know you couldn't see
every game you had to listen to the game
you had to wait for the game now these
[__] are on you know all day long the
same [__] 24 i'm like it's overkill do i
need to hear this [__] all day i want to
have some something to dream about you
know it's just like if you want to be
with a woman you don't want to see her
all the time
you want to you have something to look
forward to
that's the problem with sports
you're correct
correct and argue with you i thought he
was going to say something
[__] up my [__] god what were you going
to say oh well no i i was thinking about
that today because i was watching the uh
the the video for the uh 2004 world
series
and
i was in high school
i i'm pretty sure maybe our eighth grade
and i just can't
i can't explain how
happy i got watching that video today i
watched the first like 45 minutes
oh he's a red sox fan so yeah
and it was
i think they don't have social media
then
and i get i like i totally get why they
have it now
but there's like a mystique to it like
what nick was saying
and like i just got emotional thinking
about how like that team like really the
whole town
like everywhere you went
it wasn't even like it was just like
instead of hello like
the red sox like you see that last night
like it was pretty good it was amazing
you know there's an abundance of
podcasts
and they're coming in with shows now or
whatever and i don't get angry
some of my business is a free country
that's why we live in this country
we each have opportunities
but i tell you what i don't want to hear
anymore is like sports shows
if you can't sleep like a guy like me
some nights i get home
i can't sleep you know i get home at 11
it's not gonna happen until one i'm
already committed to it i watch those
espn shows just so i know i try to learn
what's going on right and they're
unwatchable
especially the ones that they talk shows
and they argue about sports i'm over
that why should i feel stressed out
about the yankees or the redskins
excuse
it stresses you out those shows yeah the
arguing the yelling the well i think
you're wrong simon
i see the minnesota vikings there's
underdogs here
because i know what i like
in new york wfan you know sports talk
radio but in the middle of the night 3
30 in the morning put that little
[__] radio on transistor
and you hear some nut job caller
middle three o'clock unbelievable
great he's talking to this [__] guy
at night
middle of the night overnight guy i find
it soothing i find it like
you know this guy's up people are up 3
o'clock 3 30 [__] making phone calls
arguing about [__] [__] they got to
trade him he's a [__] [__] oh
this is radio right i know right now
right now what are we gonna do i tried
with i had a buddy but it's funny you
used to shoot heroin and listen to that
[__] another 20 minutes get involved
like you go for the phone yeah you
forget the phone number yeah and he go
back to sleep and then then the argument
would come back yeah yeah you think
you're dreaming or some [__] it was a
trick that [__] radio one by your ear
it's nice it's funny little lone radio
my mother used to keep a little low
radio on and then i would [__] with him
i would grab his ankle yeah and [__]
pull his leg and i go hey go what dog
let go hurry up
they want to know if you want to talk to
pete rose on the phone
i torment them three or four times
really oh my god those are
you know
it's so funny
when you're going through [__] that is
not enjoyable in your life you go
through a rough patch
there's always this bright light
in 93 i was going to the worst part of
my divorce
the cards were gone the car was gone
i was trying to do comedy that's all i
really wanted to do
i didn't want to do a day job but i
found the pigeon who had a bunch of
valiums for sale
for like 35 cents on the dollar
and i told them to give me a box then
i'd be back in a week and i never came
back
i stayed in the [__] jersey and i was
fighting it out 1993 in new york city
the summer yeah delivering phones
delivering packages
selling tickets for a comedy club i'm
just learning the ropes you know
but my roommate at the time was on
heroin
and it was my own private little reality
show
and my job was just to torture him
but that was his thing
that i'd be sleeping and also that here
like a conversation in the middle of
night and i wake up and i'm like what
the [__]
and it'd be george
on heroin like this
with his mouth open with the [__]
string around his arm still
with a little blood coming out of his
arm wow and he'd be laying there [__]
listening to
sports radio and then the argument would
ensue and he would just get up out of
nowhere and start arguing with me
dog that's [__]
the yankees have been doing worse since
they signed that guy what the [__]
this [__] though what'd he say the
number was
and i feed him like a fake number and
he'd go for the phone
pick up the phone and start dialing and
then he'd say to me what's the number
he'd light a cigarette
and he and he'd forget the number and he
go what's the number and i go
do well and i'd give him the house phone
number
and he would call the house phone number
like three numbers
and he would just pass out
and then i would leave him like that
for about 25 minutes i go out and watch
tv on the news
leave them with the cigarette burning in
his mouth oh my god you know me i'm
going to torture you
i come back 15 minutes later
the cigarettes are about to
burn them
[Laughter]
and go george what happened to pete rose
he's like huh
and i go [__] pete rose was on the
phone
you're going to talk to him about the
1973 world series he goes
oh
bait
they don't beat
there was no pete there no pete thought
i would laugh my ass off with this
kidney oh that's funny [__] and it was
every night when i got home
so i get home from the city working all
day 9 30
and he'd already be on fire or he'd be
waiting for grandma to go to bed because
grandma
knew he was a heroin junkie
so she'd watch him like a hawk wow so
about 11 15 dog
he'd be scratching the skin off his
[__] arms
and once she crawled on the bad day
just thinking about it makes me laugh
because he'd be like the tedious side of
the bloody sabbath
and he'd be watching the tv very thing
like professional like it wasn't father
but i knew he was eating himself up
alive inside
every minute
sometimes
i knew
he wanted her to go in
and i would not i knew
that if i kept grandma out there it
would torture
so
grandma
every time she'd go okay i'm gonna go no
no grandma what's his part in the movie
and he could turn pale
he would turn pale yeah
he would turn pale i did this somewhere
two times
then i telling her grandma go to bed the
parts not to lead
and he she wouldn't be inside but ten
seconds like he would
you
good night grandma
he may believe like nothing was
happening
and all of a sudden at the count of ten
he'd just get up and run to his [__]
bathroom he'd have the the works hidden
already in there
he had the heroine in the syringe
he was ready to go
and he'd [__] go in the bathroom flag
himself up
i'd count like the 15 and then i
either knock on grandpa's door
they had a big gang in the hallway
[Laughter]
and i would hit the gang and then go
back to the chair
and then she would come out with a
what the [__] is that
and i go what grandma she goes somebody
here
what what happened and like i'm not in
grandma oh she goes
where's george and then i go i don't
know grandma i think he's in the bedroom
i try to throw her off
and he he would hear me like the i think
he's in the bedroom sleeping grandma
where is george
and i see the bedroom like did you leave
the bathroom like hold on let me see
george and she'd shoot back there and
open up the door george george is not in
here that's george in the [__]
bathroom and she would run to the
bathroom and start banging on the door
george open the bathroom and george
would open the bathroom all [__] up oh
my god he'd hide the syringe you could
still smell she'd run in there i smell
that [__] i smell that [__] i smell it
here open that [__] window does she
know oh [__] everybody knew
[Music]
what year was this
1993 was the best was grandma went to
panama for a month
and he moved into her little bedroom
george george and at that time
how he made a living was he chipped in
for rent
and what he did was he sub rented
himself
as a a framer once a month
he's very good at framing pictures yeah
that's what he does for a living
tremendous oh you mean today
still at that time when he was doing the
h
[Music]
for a while there he dropped out lived
off his living sold his car
but then once he tried to get back on
his feet he went to like his first rehab
he was still getting high a little bit
that was [__] rough because i was a
mess
i was living and working in manhattan so
on the way home i'd stop up on 178th
street and pick up a grandma tootsu for
35 bucks
i'd take the bus like nothing happened
over the bridge i'd go home and do a
couple bumps watch tv
jerk off call an ex-girlfriend try to
make it come over and suck my dick
she'd say no you know stupid [__] i was
a kid yeah well i was on coke but he was
back there doing h
so he got a job
as a framer
and he cut a deal with them to work four
10 hour days
and because he was that good he goes i
don't want to [__] around
i want to work for 10 hour days left
three days off oh my god framing houses
framing pictures
at a mall in paramus
we lived in cliffside park
they were paying them a good hourly wage
and a base salary and a percentage of
what pictures
whatever he framed that they sold
he was making a nice dollar and he was
working brother
and he would probably do a little taste
to heroin in the morning to keep him
together all day
and i had a couple of friends that were
on heroin i had him and bonehead i had
another friend bonehead he was always on
heroin he had his own plumbing business
you wouldn't know it because in the
daytime he was a businessman
at night we go into [__]
washington square park and go to
mcsally's air house and [__] get
pills and [__] heroin from him and
he'd disappear in the bathroom
and i'd have to drive the van home it
was tremendous when you were a kid this
tremendous [__]
but that other guy what did heroin do
what kind of high is that yeah that's
pretty
oh my god
i remember being a kid and going to the
bronx in the early 70s those people were
everywhere yeah
nodding on the cross light waiting for
the light to change it's just [__]
crazy that's a bad drug it's a bad drug
right
and the [__] they were pumping into them
that all that american gangster
and nikki barnes and oil stories let me
tell you something like any other
criminal enterprise in the movie it
looks alluring and it looks okay
but what they did to that community
no matter how generous nicki barn was
or the character that uh
played before he was denzel's you know
when denzel was his bodyguard that guy
yeah they were both generous businessmen
but their general business was heroin
right which was just [__] this troll
destroyed a lot of lives a lot of people
and then the maf you're cutting on the
business the jews had it first
and the mafia cut it on that you know
because it was [__] you a fifty
thousand dollar investment
you walk away with four hundred thousand
dollar profit yeah one knucklehead like
me and you 400 000
takes us three weeks to sell it what are
you [__] nuts we're doing one of
those every month yeah 200 g's a month
just standing on the corner
we're going to stay in that stupid
[__] corner that's why the whole wise
guys they didn't want you to mess around
with uh they call it
something because it's a lot of dough
but
if you sold it and i'm your captain
did you tell me it's book making money
even though i've heard rumors that
you're selling heroin i'm still going to
take it
right it was always a very two-edged
sword right if you know how to present
it the right way you presented it yeah
now if they question you but they found
out
what corner am i in
what corner am i well no they said
you're
in cahoot for joe diaz
i know jordan's for 10 years
i know he'd done something he came to me
for an all-purpose loan he's paying big
payments
that's my partnership with him
so you're not the heroin business no i
get payments from him from [__]
yeah why'd he tell somebody he's in
business with me i don't know was he in
a mess
how big is your envelope caller i'm
getting a big ammo what do you care
where it's coming from it's not heroin
let's move on that's what it
you're making money i'm making money
he's got an envelope right okay you're
the biggest
what's going on no i'm happy yeah what's
going on that's that's what happened
if i say no to you
if i see you usually you can't [__]
[__] midgets in the ass no more
all right you're gonna stop [__]
midgets in the ass
but how can i tell you to stop doing
something that i'm trying to make money
on
don't you want free money
if i came to you every week
and gave you 500 every friday
and you took it and your wife said you
don't take it no more
he's a child pornographer
are you going to take my nickel every
week
or you're going to turn your back okay
i'm getting a nickel who knows who knows
what people's judgment is yeah but
that's what the mafia that doesn't care
right they don't [__] give a [__]
looking at the end they all found out
they were all selling him
at the end in the end yeah all of them
were double crossing each other right
all of them said don't do this
and then there's a way to tiptoe around
what if yeah lee wants to get into
heroin but lee could only move three
kilos a month
but i know a way for lee to sell eight
kilos a month the only problem is lee's
got to run the whole operation
what i'm gonna do is get lee started
right at least i'm an owner i'm 50
percent in
leigh's not in the mafia it doesn't
matter lee's selling the heroin
and
he's loyal and he's going to give me 50
which you're going to get a [__]
taste of nicki what the [__] do you give
a [__]
and then you're going to come to me and
then it goes bro there's a thousand
rumors going around that you sell i
don't know
who am i selling heroin with the [__]
little jew no
i lent them money
if he sells heroin that's his business
right how he pays my loan back
that's my [__] business
you get a piece of those loans right
well i didn't know you put it that way
yeah
there's no drugs involved
whatever he does he's a jew
he's gonna do it
yeah he ain't bothering nobody now
now let's pretend
he i did blend him money and he's paying
me back
but at the end of the month he's
starting to reach out he's [__]
around with the chinese yeah he's
[__] around with some brothers up and
home yeah did you don't feel safe
so the jew wants to pay us a taste
so he could throw our name around right
that's it
they don't know that you're going out at
night with a [__] half a package
worth
eighty two thousand dollars right
taking it to florida the [__]
some puerto ricans down there
waiting for a [__] envelope they
don't know that they don't care they
don't want to know you don't need to
tell them
[Music]
if you went to your captain and said
listen
i'm doing a heroin deal and i'm gonna
make 80 000 on the way back i'm going to
come over and drop 30. yeah [__] you
you think that guy's gonna tell you
don't do the deal
[__] you you're gonna give him 30 g's
out of your 80 and nobody knows nothing
you don't have to give a taste upstairs
he could give a taste upstairs and tell
him it's anything
just to cover his ass
in case you ever tell him it was heroin
money
so he'll take it
but he'll give a piece upstairs this is
something that he bumped into right what
do you mean nikki bumped into yeah i
don't know when he bumped into something
with the [__] music industry he's
running up and running with a bunch of
[__] little italian kids jumping up
and down italian
that's it [__] gets busted for heroin
didn't you bring me money yeah i don't
[__] know
he's not with me
but he i like the money years ago also
he came to me and he said he was
reaching out
and if he gave me a little taste would i
protect him i don't need to know his
business was literally selling hot shoes
that's it right and besides i gave you a
taste
that's what that was yeah you know i
wouldn't give you drug money yeah okay
forget it
everybody looks the other way yeah no
they don't give a [__] you know on paper
if you're selling heroin you give me 10
grand a week
i don't give a [__]
that's 40 000 a month
can you imagine somebody haven't handed
you 480 thousand dollars a year
and he reports just to you
kim the other guy paul castellano had
two dudes
that he they just reported to him one
guy
that was on the board of directors
of tannenbaums
that guy
i forget what his name is
board of directors of tanner bombs like
that in supermarket and all over new
york whatever
and i was telling lee that what this guy
did
was he put an extra lane in every
supermarket
that the store didn't know about
that went right upstairs to the mob can
you imagine oh really they had i don't
know how many supermarkets what was the
lane consists of
checkout
1970 oh it was lane number 13. always
had corporate head out the corporate
headquarters never knew about it
so all that money went right to the
mafia the lane number 13 at all there
was a mob lane my blade so if you were
in row 13
whatever went into that cash register
nobody knew about a guy came every day
emptied it
and took it to the [__] and took it to a
room and threw it in the kick
it could be three four hundred hours but
what have you got what was that store
strout tannenbaums or something wow
it's a really [__] up world bro what
people do for cash it don't matter they
don't give a [__]
what do you think lisa how you feeling
buddy you're [__] up it's all over hey
you're lucky uncle nick brought you some
pizza and i'm napkins
he was at him before you had to hear him
people he's like ah
i don't know you said you should take
the pizza with you i'm gonna throw it
away anyway you can have it i know you
can have it you could have heat it up
you put it in the oven don't put it in
the dough
is that constantly oh it is yeah we
don't want to put that in the microwave
we're gonna need another couple of stars
now
look i'm saying he's ready he ain't
ready he knows you know what drug i had
when i had the epidurals last year the
the michael jackson drug that was
[__] good i gotta tell you that how
did they give it to you
and put me on my stomach everybody in
the room and an injection i guess they
froze me and
and they said we're going to give you
this [__] propathol you're going to
go out in 10 seconds
but i'll tell you where i went to like
some happy
happy [__] place i was so happy
like you have a dream where you feel
like yeah i mean i i never was so happy
and then i woke up crying bawling like
crying my ass off but i was so happy
when i took that drug
i wonder why michael got
yeah that's a powerful drug
can you imagine why you feel that happy
of your body like it just takes over
your dopamine like even though it was
weird yeah it's it's weird i was in this
place
very very happy place yeah warm it's
warm then i woke up and i was crying and
i was it's a weird [__] feeling yeah
but when you go out those first [__]
six or seven minutes i couldn't believe
they said you know you're gonna be out
in 10 seconds
i said you sure you sure i don't
remember nothing nothing after that
you're talking about [__] yeah if they
tape those you're definitely not [__]
for like an hour after you're out one
guy talked to me when i did my elbow he
said my eyeballs were open the whole
time and i was talking smack through the
whole thing i said really he said yeah
because you were really funny your eyes
were wide open as they were white it was
wide open
and you were talking
nonstop
it's it's crazy what you're saying
when you don't know what you're saying
because dreaming is weird you know
i hate those [__] dreams where you're
trying to wake up you can't wake up
man and
you're fighting the dream you know i
have weird dreams in hotels
i do too
especially when i have to eat edibles to
fall asleep
but i have to eat edibles to help me go
to sleep and i go overboard to get
really high yeah you go to sleep and
your dreams are in color and vivid
and you have [__] dreams i had a
dream that i left my wife and daughter
to go back with my high school
sweetheart who got rid of her [__]
boyfriend to live down the rumps in new
jersey oh boy this chick sucked 80 dicks
oh by the time she was 25.
i'm gonna leave my wife to go back
you're gonna go back to that
and i woke up
so many dicks were in their mouth
i woke up thinking what the [__] and i
like i still talk to i like i respect
the
bloodshot girl which one yeah
i still love it at that she's like one
of my favorite people she always had my
background
[Music]
but i had one of those dreams this
weekend
and i had a dream that i was somewhere
and my wife came in with a baby
and she didn't bring the baby over or
she didn't come over and say hello
so i went up to her a little while later
i go why don't you come up to me
and she goes what did you end up doing
last night and i go nothing
and she goes how come
somebody called and said you're on the
run
the cops are looking for you for like a
a stabbing or something that was
horrible wow that was hard in the dream
in the dream i thought the cops were
looking for me that's horrible
i don't even know what the cops are
looking for before i can't lie
i don't know why but i remember telling
my wife why didn't you come to me and
she was like i couldn't
the cops were about to arrest you they
were standing like 20 feet from me
why were they going to harass me and i
don't after that no
[Music]
yes they do i think so
what are you doing
i don't know i think it has it
definitely has to do with what you're
thinking about at the moment but get
back deja vu
all the time
airports planes
stuff like that do you feel you were
there before yeah
really it's interesting i always thought
so too i get them once
not not every time when i was a kid i
got them so much
that before i even heard that mumbo
jumbo about reincarnation
i thought i was reincarnated
like i knew i hadn't lived before
i knew all that stuff that's [__]
crazy to admit but that's the truth you
go to church joey
uh lately evan i'll hit it this sunday
i'll hit a 7 30 masters sunday if i can
it's very interesting for me now how i
feel about it
there's no pressure
when i go i have a great time take the
bread
sure
sure drink the wine no no no never that
gives you the [__] fluids dirty
a bunch of people don't brush their
teeth i know
you gotta see how i drink it i i put my
own i put my mouth
above the thing like that's my shabbos
don't even i know it's been a shower but
for some reason i get a kick out of it
don't drink that [__] that [__] makes
you sick as a dog you think so i know
for a fact
sources it don't it don't take a [__]
genius to know that
drinking out of a cup that a hundred
people gonna drink them
and let's say your number past ten yeah
your odds go up more every time yeah
i'll stop now you got my head yeah i'm
thinking
you tell them beautiful thank you but
none next time
you eat the cookie you say a prayer
and a rancher you put a film in the
basket yeah
means let's go okay
[Music]
that's good yeah no it's pretty funny
how
my philosophy on church especially
how much i believed
and when i stepped away although you
know once your mom dies at 16 you lose
you believe
what god takes your mother at 16 no god
[__] it
i'm not going to [__] church normal
why am i going to go to church that's
all [__] yeah so i stepped the [__]
out of it after i got locked up i went
back to church for a while
and i liked it
the guy married me i went to church on
my own there on sunday
but i got forced into that communist
master 11 o'clock that's too much time
for uncle joey
that's too much coming yeah that hour
and a half for a week tell you what i've
been doing is the five o'clock five
o'clock is the point it's sunday not bad
no i found one with a lot of good music
half hour yeah 40 man but the music's
good
you know my son's school i was going to
his uh school masters last few years did
a carmelites i actually like maybe
because it was a high school i don't
know i just kind of dug the caramel
lights a little bit a little different
just a little different style
it was really
yeah they're catholic the cat but they
wear brown
they wear brown
and um i don't know they just seem
not as up you know i don't know they
just seem they're not as uptight as the
regular priest but they're you know
they're catholics too
musics are pretty good i like the music
like i said i enjoyed twice a month now
how old is your daughter now four and a
half wow she's not right she goes to her
church with a mother down the corner
some whatever stomach at church
uh at four and a half i can't believe
you have a daughter four and a half
that's wild
really
and it gets wild every day nick and you
went through it she's falling there
she's a girly girl tonight she was
showing me a new dresses that she got
with mommy on saturday
she loves the skirt daddy don't you love
the skirt you know little girls are the
best she's the goods yeah when they get
older they get very complicated
but when they're little there's
something about little girls they're
just like the most sweetest things
they're just so innocent she runs the
joint yeah a there's a scene in
narcos when his brother-in-law comes to
visit him
and pablo tells him he goes jesus she's
getting bigger every day
she's beautiful and bob mogo's brother
at the end of the day she runs the house
i just pay the bills and she tells me
what to do
and that's exactly how i live and people
i had to meet somebody this morning
i told to listen i thought i took the
schedule this week was i'll pick her up
at school at 5 30. we're cool
i'm packing my computer i'm packing my
notebook i'm really going to meet this
cat she comes in this morning
daddy where you going i'm not going to
mean no no
you're taking me to school you want to
go and i go i got no chance
[Music]
yeah let's go
turn off the light it was hysteric when
she tells me to turn off the light she
says turn up the light
away remember when she slammed the door
on my face oh yeah she's just tired
she's funny huh funny what's her name
mercy so she gives me she walks me to
the door
daddy let's go come on daddy
come on daddy
i walk outside i open the door she jumps
in my mother puts her seat seatbelt on
you know it's a whole thing in the
morning this morning i walked in with
her
i took the [__] lunch thing from her
i took the cup out put it in the box for
her and i walked into the refrigerator
she goes no daddy give it back to me i
want to put it in there
you know it's a [__] trip like that's
it like i'm her assistant yeah you know
there's a time when
i can be [__]
busy as [__] at the computer
have three pages open i'm about to book
a plane ticket i got this offer on the
table i want to see if i can make the
date i got to call him back by 4 30.
this guy keeps calling me this guy keeps
calling me
and i'm ready to [__] put the deal
together i'm ready to go and she comes
in
and i got earphones on
with music so i can't hear
and she'll come in dog tap me i'm
looking to give her a kiss and she'll
push me at the same time
put her leg over my leg and crawl up and
go
daddy put on trolls
and that's it yeah i gotta close all
three files
go to youtube
and she types in
the last year i had her type in
everything tr
with the other one uh the other one this
come by the the [__] smurfs yeah so
everything we type in i make a type of
them since free and
f
p
z
doesn't matter how old she's smart i'll
sit there with her for a little while
and when she'll go daddy down
daddy down that means i have to scroll
for right but about a week ago i got up
to go and talk on the phone she figured
it out that's it wow so now i'll be
sitting down with her she'll try to be
sweet
touch my face
take on my hand and giggle
and then after that video ends as soon
as the switches you're looking me and go
daddy can you go now
like what do you mean go i'm watching
this for you she goes daddy can you go
now that means that's it
and she'll get up off me and i'll get up
she'll sit on the chair i push her
and i go in the living room and i listen
for her to go daddy that means i gotta
go in there and press the next video but
now she figured out how to do that
so she'll sit in my office for an hour
and a half dog
and she knows how to click the videos
she knows how to skip to the [__]
commercials lee
yeah
unbelievable but they learn no and this
is what i live with i live on
borrowed time when i wake up in the
morning i don't know if she's coming in
the room right i hope she does she's my
daughter
but i don't want to be manhandled either
you know what i'm saying she just
she's just a gorilla she'll sit there
playing me like a [__] fiddle
last night i got home she go daddy can i
sleep man listen
you know my ears [__] up and i can't
have you hit it with your foot put your
[__] head in some
tomorrow night i forgot to be in the bed
yeah she does it every sunday night
every other sunday we will sleep with us
on sunday night we have family night
we watch a movie and her and her mother
eat popcorn and they go to bed and i
come in like an hour later
so uh
last night she asked are we doing it
today oh no it's next sunday
but
what i'll do is if my ear didn't hurt i
would do it this week but i'll do
tomorrow night
i forgot i even said that to her
she got home from school today
she didn't
she got next to me we watched tv
we watched wooly kazam coconuts
she rubbed my legs she rubbed my finger
and then she goes daddy how's your ear
and they go pretty good you see i kissed
it i made it better
that means i could sleep with you guys
tonight i go god damn it
i forgot she set me up this afternoon so
listen man you learn from your children
you see yourself you think of your
self at that age oh yeah you're like
what the [__] was i doing at four and a
half yeah i was running around the bar
she's a little daycare with a bunch of
hindu kids they're all twins
there's more hindu twins at that school
there's three sets of hindu twins
pre-school and there was four
two of them went back to india
and they were adorable two girls they
were adorable these two girls i was this
close from going nick come pick me up
forget about it we're going to manage
these two hindu girls
show up in there with a pilot for disney
whatever yeah about two indian girls
that live with a black family and
hauling forget about it we're making
billions a lot of money we cut that dude
in from atlanta that dresses up like a
woman yeah they got abused by his father
what's his name
what's his name that shoots all these
movies in the atlanta guys oh that guy
tyler perry and we tell him this is a
black spectacle oh man that's a zombie a
black family adopts two hindu twins in
the bronx
are you kidding me and then after a
while they're becoming a band we put
them on empire
and then it's like cross pollination
it's like when the green hornet when i'm
batman we just set them loose after that
that does sound like a home run
that was on me what do you think you're
dealing with joey bananas
what do you got coming out on dvd
anything
you shot [__] four years ago that's
getting finished now i got the couple of
things i mean i got this
couple of uh this movie called the list
i got a couple of a couple of horror
flicks i don't even know the name of
them
um then i'm trying to still sell this
pilot over the hill which
i don't know we might find a digital
platform for that
uh next week i'll be on the kevin kevin
james show um you know a lot of a lot of
little things
things that i'm not really you know that
excited about right now
i'd be much happier if we could sell
this little show i did because there's
actually some good [__] in it
so
we'll see maybe one of these companies
hulu or youtube red i mean
you know they say everybody's looking
for content but you know until you get
out there with your show yeah you know
what we have something similar but we do
yeah we have something similar yeah
the guy on netflix was like well they're
talking about the aziz show and go yeah
it's funny i go but what does that got
to do with my show
it's not i'm nothing like him you know i
i don't
i feel like i'm the last of the mo i
don't know i feel like a guy who's like
you know it's like you know you're just
trying to find your way
you know and it's like i've been doing a
lot of little [__] but it's like
this was kind of fun to do because i
felt like i actually did something even
though it's not perfect i feel like
i actually did some good stuff in it
but you need the proper writers the
proper support to get it to the place
where it could be good it could be good
because naida was in it was really funny
he did hbo shows
that's what
yeah you know which is a good little
last hurrah to go out with five years on
hbo that's what i'm looking for you go
out like julius brown
soldier go out like i said you end up at
a [__] home with a bird on your
shoulder yeah and tony yes comes to
visit exactly and ask you if you still
remember me yeah yeah i mean look i've
been watching dice you know that's not
bad you're random jersey that's it
i mean so what episode of dice did you
watch tonight the new season i watched
the new season last night where he was
like he had a part in a
in a martin scorsese movie that his best
friend wrote milkshake
and it was
and this freaking swedish guy was
screaming was the director
and then michael imperioli played like
the star of it he was playing the guy
based on dice
he was a little over the top but uh dice
played like his best friend
and dice was actually good in it but he
wound up getting fired he wanted him
getting quiet
and then mickey rock was in his house
mickey rock who looks
i love mickey rocky this doesn't look
really good
and he was like mickey what are you
doing here what are you doing in my
house mickey
and mickey was like out to [__] like
kill himself and kill him at the end but
you know dice talked him out of it
and then i watched a little bit of the
first uh episode of curb like my man
larry david's back and funny [__] man
[__] larry david makes me laugh you
like larry david i forgot he was even
though yeah he's back man with jb smoove
[__] funny jb smooth became he fired
his assistant then he was like give me
that [__] job
jamie smooth is funny
and uh oh man he just cracks me up i
like larry david one thing we gotta give
a shout out to our boy my brother felipe
esparza yes his hbo special lee went to
the event
[Music]
and uh oh good man thank you guys we're
all from the bottom of my heart for
supporting him he was on the show last
week
and uh we saved them for the end of the
month to help him
get eyeballs on this special and you
guys [__] came through
so thank you very much for that thank
you for the support on my niece
she's going home tomorrow
she had the uh last bone marrow test
today sugar the result in 24 hours
but again thank you for all your support
donations and love it to the rough
two or three months between florida
houston
puerto rico and all everybody on [__]
social media asking you for a buck
it's been difficult so thank you very
much especially going to the holiday
season man
and that's it my brother uncle nikki poo
we need that sauce yeah you'll get that
sauce me and john let's take out this
[__] we're gonna get it out sauce
with the bread yeah that's why you sell
it you all believe me listen we make the
sauce but the secret is
i want people to stop
and pay 7.99 for six slices of bread and
a container of that sauce together
forget the spaghetti and meatballs
eat with the carbs you might die
tomorrow that's the model of the company
eat the carbs you might die tomorrow eat
the coffee fresh nice italian bread
sliced a little bit of montaki pretty
good sauce for a jar and you dip it into
that [__] cold sauce or warm however
you want it
we give you a cup and that was heaven
right that was [__] delicious if you
love food i know that especially if you
want to eat at night and keep it light
six thin slices of bread ain't gonna
send you to the hospital especially
you're gonna get up and running no way
you wake up with little carbs
sauce put your [__] stomach
put a little [__] juice in there yeah
and that's it yeah i mean exactly how to
do it no i know i mean no i have my
little secret so what's your secret for
the world series what's the route the
yankees
beat tomorrow when tomorrow night the
twinkies yankees beat the twinkies
tomorrow night then they play and then
we play the cleveland indians we upset
them oh [__] in four games oh [__] then
we take the red sox i just smack them
like smack them smack them and and six
what do you think ladies
why why are we two games ahead in the
alice
yeah
i don't know i haven't watched the
season zone
playoffs are starting next week oh
that's [__] oh [__] new season i
know that second half
i'm not even talking [__] i'm just
laughing who is the better team
all the yankees are definitely a better
team than i think they're a better team
than the red side even though the red
sox beat them by two games
yankees beat them head to head 11 to
eight okay so but you know that doesn't
mean [__] now because now it's a new
year postseason so it don't matter what
you did now you're now you're in the
dance can you win it who has better
pitching
uh
the yankees have a deeper bullpen they
have a great closer on greg kimble
better starters though
uh well you got chris sell you got one
stud but he's never won in the
postseason right it's close and price is
in the bullpen now but he's doing pretty
good yeah he's doing throwing bullets
out of the bullpen even though he's
never done anything in the postseason
but it could be a good weapon out of the
bullpen i actually think that's a good
move for them that seems to be working
out i got to be optimistic you know they
call
with the baby bombers young guns
i'm not saying we're going to go all the
way but i think we're going to make some
noise you always have to root for a red
toxin he's serious i always root for
that there's nothing like yankee but the
yankee red sox brings out the hatred in
me
you know it's like the cousin that you
hate
it's the cousin you [__] despise but
you know you respect them
there's something about the yankees and
the red sox when you get them together
it's magical and fenway is awesome not
like that new yankee stadium i mean
you'll see tomorrow night they'll be
these rich seats and then half of them
are [__] empty
and they should put seed fillers in
there and pack them in people got to
stay in their seats
yeah these [__] seats that are always
empty now what happened yesterday at the
dodger what happened i wanted to stadium
football yesterday it was so empty
they had to put tarp on the [__]
stadium or some [__] is that the charges
or something
this isn't moronic they can't even
support the rams why would you move
another team
you know down here the chargers who
really belong in san diego keep them in
san diego don't move them here and it's
bad you got the rams back who will
eventually walk
can they move back now though that's
what could they they lost face yeah
unless somebody builds a stadium you
know but i don't know these guys that
want a new stadium and then you know but
they got a good fan base
san diego is a little sports town
la is not really a sports town they have
staff sports fans here but they're not
it's not really a sports town
i sit here and i listen to you
and i can't uh tell you how much the
baseball world
needs a baseball podcast with that voice
and that passion especially for the
yankees
i don't i think you could do the whole
thing
yeah i think your whole spectrum is the
yankees and fighting for the yankees
yeah that's with my whole having people
call you and argue with you and you
light them on fire and help
them from time to time i get them i
think that's your show right maybe
that's
you know i always tell lee it's a good
show i always tell we should do things
certain ways the east coast way you know
there's been a couple situations lately
where
you hate to say it somebody's in the jam
somebody's kids get married
and you as an adult and a human being go
you know what nick's always been good to
me his daughter's getting married
let me do the right thing and you uh
you bro wedding present
and then you put money in the envelope
because you're busy working that weekend
i was in vegas working you know and
then i said to me oh jesus christ they
never sent us saying thank you note
and they got married in june
it's [__] october
and you're like a shame on them i mean
you know what are you going to do
there was somebody else that my wife did
something
she never got a thank you card no man
somebody that again no thank you god i
get home someday
there's a card on my desk and i look at
it
and it's from my buddy the daughters my
daughter's godfather
and i opened it and it's a thank you
card
for the flowers when his dad died
september [__] like eighth or
something
i'm like you see what i'm saying people
think i'm wrong about [__]
there's still people who think like me
right they didn't wait a month like this
is this is ridiculous because i came
home
that cash was in that envelope on my
dinner mantel
for two months
and we looked at each other like when we
gonna spend this cash obviously she's
not gonna come and get it when i went
over that i gave the envelope to the dad
i still haven't heard a [__] thank
you or
nothing it's amazing how people take
[__] for granted oh i know
it really and you know what that means
it just means a lot when you when
someone is there or does something and
you just say hey i appreciate that no no
no just
you know this this generation they're
not
they barely ever say you know let me get
some kids you know i've been around a
lot of kids the last few years and
you know you see the ones that have
madness i've treated them here they're
like i treat them like they're my
extended family but
the ones that really appreciate you know
and then there's takers the ones that
they come in they trash the joint
they leave like animals they don't pick
up after and like you know you just you
get tired even even some family members
i don't want to name names but
you know you know you just go
there's [__] goblins you know it's
like you know just have some manners
nobody has men nah no more they come
they eat they walk out like animals you
know the people that took me and when my
mother died i knew them for like five
years i was going to the house every
wednesdays and eating pasta
but the main thing how i got tight with
them was because they got a pool
and when you got a built-in pool in 1970
you were the hot commodity neighborhood
so everybody came everybody came to your
house jumped in the pool
people who got even though you got a
party and they went on the list
they would still get a jump in your pool
and after they pissed in your pool and
[__] scratched their balls
they left the pool as is they left the
mask out yeah the thing they were
blowing out up the things uh and i had a
pool for a while in the above ground
pool when we were above the ground yeah
once we had a program
we had the boat funny so somebody
punctured the [__] net and then the
pool drains yeah that happened every
year that's how the summer ends
somebody jumps in there with a knife in
their pocket right and next to you
[__] instead of the next day you got
two feet of water and it's green it
turns green immediately yeah it's
[__] quick if that thing ain't
running
you see all the piss right then you got
a chance to glue the side and fill it up
with fresh water and
it's still cold for three [__] days
but
oh my god my memories are cleaning that
pool
every morning you have to get up and
take the leaves off the top no and then
you had to put the vacuum on the bottom
of the pool yeah and take the algae off
the pool and it would develop like this
then you had to test the water
yeah those are the above ground and then
the other probably go to the benders
and test that pool like it was crazy you
had an in-ground and you thought the
people were rich you know yeah when you
had an in-ground pool
you were a movie star a movie star
[__] sinatra was coming over the
house i had my first [__] house i
bought in tarzana and the reason i
bought it the pool looked like a pond
and had a grotto and i i was like wow i
couldn't believe i had this i was like
look at this [__] i never went in it
much but the grotto i had all kinds of
ideas for the grotto
and but i didn't really take advantage
of it completely but hey you just
couldn't believe like i'm like who would
have a pool like that growing up unless
you you know had money you know maybe
one family in the neighborhood had that
i don't know they owned a mcdonald's
franchise or some [__]
are you getting residuals for reals
from reels they play your [__] don't
they yeah i get a lot of you know i've
done great with uh actually blue bloods
on syndication i mean i wish i would
have did more episodes but man
i never saw a syndication like that i
mean even nypd blue i don't think
they must have sold this show it's a
very popular show it's unbelievable it's
still doing
really really well syndication-wise
um you know yeah you could you know it
keeps you alive keeps you alive i mean
that's why man the more episodes the
better it would have been every sunday
at 601 i go to sag after dot net
and i look what residual checks are
coming in i don't i just i just and then
i look at in processing that's how
jewish i am really i look at what's on
the list you told me that and i did that
once or twice
i don't do it no more i just you got to
see what's going on no they keep coming
in you got to check it out you got to
see what's coming in because you might
miss one or two of this and god forbid
you call
you have to go if you're going to sag
after there's a list really you go to
and you type your name and within 72
hours you get an email wow they'll go
nick tutorial come down to office box
six
and print up the label we give you oh my
god let me tell you what happens and
this is shocking you've been in the
business for 30 [__] years
you're going to go down their neck and
they're going to hand you
a stack of checks that your jaw's gonna
drop
and then you're gonna go
what the [__] is this
what do you mean money you never claimed
money that
where is this they this is sack you go
to wilshire sag after i've never done it
yes you have to go down there i did this
10 years ago my wife is an accountant
okay so she goes one day let's take a
ride down there i got the thing and i
got your thing we went down there and
you asked what came back
go online and start it uh checks missing
checks or something it's called
see if you have a check at after sag
you press your name and or you look for
the names you don't have your name on
the list oh i know i have money out
there what you do is you go down there
you give them whatever they say in your
nick they're gonna come back with a
stack of check
and they're gonna tell you excuses why
they didn't mail that check that your
heart's gonna stop
you're gonna get addresses
that you've never even seen before wow
from
how did this happen so it's unclaimed
the money unclaimed money yeah but do
you do you have to do any research
before you go to them you have to go
online there's something on
sag-aftra.org
and you go to sag-aftra.org that's how
you check your residuals and stuff
on sundays now it's not whatever it used
to be
and just keep looking for payments and
in there somewhere i'll say
lost checks unclaimed checks do what it
tells you to do what the process is yeah
once and i think there was a bunch of
[__]
i went down there one time with my wife
and they threw me a stack and an
envelope
and the reasons the addresses they had
sent started
did not make sense
[Music]
they were sending address to address as
well i mean one time i had something
where they had me and my son confused
he's not even interested yesterday no
this is what they do i had four or five
thousand i had a bunch of yes no i got
to the bottom of that and i got that
money yeah you get that money it's got
that money it's down there waiting for
you it's down there waiting for you it's
so [__] weird and you cannot believe
you look first off you look at after and
go can i ask you a question
why didn't you guys get my address
and put this in the [__] middle to go
how do you find the unclaimed stuff you
go on the line sag after well that went
down there me and my wife looked at him
and said
since you had all these
why didn't you send this to the address
yeah and they said well since we got
these we really didn't know what yeah i
just was like let me ask you a question
how did you know this in the build
address mm-hmm yeah and they were
stuttered huh well maybe that i just
went i definitely know i have some
something out there i don't know how
much and the fuck-ups
are just
possible so you're saying it could be oh
you're going to see a lot of money they
you i know for you know i know for a
fact
because there's 10 uh whatever your last
name is
that's ten of them
they're gonna have checks for you that
belong to your brother and ida
and they're going to have checks for
them
that they'll have your name on really
because somewhere along the line
some assistant spilled coffee
on the paperwork and the sack paperwork
your address weren't blind she had one
glasses she wasn't paying attention
she typed in tutorial nicholas
george henry when did you do this i did
this about 10 years ago when i first met
my wife
and we were flat broke maybe even 12
years ago you got a stack of checks my
wife also did one for the state
and i picked up a stack of checks
we tried doing one for jersey because i
told to listen i had 20 000 jobs
god knows god knows i know god knows
what's out there give it a shot if
you're broken home right now
and you're from kentucky go to
kentucky's website
and look to see if unclaimed checks from
the state
that means that one time you hurt
yourself
and you claim disability and they told
you they were only giving you 12 weeks
what the doctor told you was you were
getting paid for 18 and those six checks
are waiting for you and they probably
gave you 800 a check you don't [__]
know
and you claim it and your jaw drops yeah
and with you guys there's tutorials
you move two or three times you're in
the house you had the house in new
jersey
that's not that's bad
because that's their excuse well we sent
that yeah because i used to get checks
there too yeah so they're going to go i
used to get checked out
we sent checks to new jersey and they
all came back yeah so why didn't you
send it to my new agent well we didn't
know where you lived well you know where
to [__] send them i mean it's [__]
crazy wow so that's what will shock you
that you have checks down there that are
significant
there's some checks that maybe they
showed a tv show and again
sent it to the tarzana address and it's
top of the [__] game residual that's
like what you know there's a bunch of
[__] like that they make mistakes like
that and
you look at these people you go
did they make these mistakes tonight
for you not to cast these checks
well they just made the mistakes
questing well i lived just now before i
moved into this place
i was getting checks every three months
for some dude from bet
for two thousand bucks
i thought about sending my his name on
and deposited i go why do this
this is actual theft
so one day the kindness of my car
actually called
bt and i said accounting i like to gain
the name and the ad just go yeah we have
i go listen i got three checks from here
for two grand
which is six grand he don't live you
know
and they go what's the address i told
them
think all right we won't send checks
that no more two weeks later i got
another check
a month later i got another check they
don't they don't give a [__] though
sometimes they're on the other computer
that don't [__] enter
who knows brother you probably didn't
have another address to
to replace him i know for a fact
especially if you've been in the union
for 30 [__] years yeah which you have
been
i'm coming up about 30 now
30 [__] yeah yeah i'm doing 20 so
we're getting [__] old my brother
i'm happy you took the time you're a
[__] gentleman thank you i'm the
scholar i love my pleasure
let me talk to your people about
something listen
the holidays are coming you know what
you don't mess around
you want to look sharp you want to look
tight maybe you're single maybe you're
ending a relationship and you just want
to look like you belong
looking good doesn't need to cost you a
fortune
5'4 club is revolutionizing the way men
shop
each month they send you a curated box
of two or three items that are hard
hand-picked
to match the current season and ready
for this your style they've been helping
men with fashion for over 15 years and
shipped to a hundred over a hundred
thousand men every single month
they know what they're doing so if you
don't that's okay five four club will
help you build your wardrobe
one month at a time that's it
no more messing around because when you
look good you feel good and that's one
of the facts on life all right so this
is how it works
you get 120 worth to close for just 60 a
month again
you can pause or cancel at any time no
commitments
and as a five five four club member
you'll also receive a fifty percent off
items in their online shop and access to
exclusive members only items free
shipping and size exchanging okay throw
out the stigma that being well dressed
will cost you a fortune those days are
done with at 5 4 club they found a way
to make great looking clothes affordable
for everyone
54 club understands that your time is
extremely valuable why waste at the mall
wandering around the stores
they've been the leading menswear brand
for over 15 years you can trust them
with your wardrobe here's what i'm going
to do go to 54club.com right now and
then the promo code joey they're going
to give you 50 off your first launch
package plus you ready for this a free
pair of glasses that's 50 off your first
package at 5-4 club spelled
five
f-o-u-r
club.com promo code joey
54.com promo code joey j-o-e-y
get listen
the holidays are three months away you
don't want to look like something's got
shot
go to five four club dot com right now
impressing joey and let's get your
wardrobe tuned up looking good smooth
like somebody who belongs in the room
who's responsible all right i love you
guys go to fivefourclub.com right now
and enter promo code joey also you want
to look good on the outside you want to
feel good on the inside it's time you go
to honor.com right now
and start your health campaign before
the new year stop kidding yourself i'm a
fat [__] too i need to get changed my
life too i'm losing weight but i'm stuck
at whatever they call a plateau who the
[__] are you kidding you won't stop
eating your fat [__] take the mayonnaise
out of the tuna take the mayonnaise out
of the tuna anyway don't worry about
another that go to honor.com right now
for supplements to help you start
your goals and health and whatever you
want whether you're looking for shroom
tech sport or shroom tech immune
or alpha brain with a 30 day money-back
guarantee for the hemp force protein
which is just sensational
the flavor the cocoa the cacao is
brilliant okay and it's hemp
protein which is better for the
digestion to digest easier listen i can
go on for hours do yourself a favor go
to honor.com right now
if you see something you like put it in
the box and press in church bam
yeah 10 percent off delivered right to
your door okay who's better than you
guys i'm going to thank
the54club.com
and i also want to thank honor.com i
want to thank my men nick the tool i
want to thank you people for being
[__] savages
have a great night stay black i have a
great day stay black and uh
my heart goes out to the the victims in
las vegas also puerto rico
i'm not forgetting about you stay black
have a great day
a little something for my main man uh
what's his name
i forgot i'm so high
tom petty tom patty i love you guys have
a great
week